आई एम ऑडिबल
हेलो अब्दुल हेलो एंड आई एम फाइन तो सबको
मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है प्लीज बताना एक
बार चैट में यस या नो आई एम ऑडिबल
प्लीज बताइए एक बार चैट में सबको मेरी
आवाज सुनाई दे रही है या नहीं सुनाई दे
रही? प्लीज बताइए।
ओके थैंक यू मानसिं
शर्मा ओके मनीष कश्यप ओके थैंक यू थैंक यू
एवरीवन तो थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं दो से 5
मिनट का तो आपका कोई भी अगर डाउट है
रिलेटेड टू प्रीवियस क्लास तो आप मुझसे
पूछ सकते हैं उसके बाद हम क्लास को
स्टार्ट करेंगे ओके
या आई एम फाइन
अब्दुल और देयर आर
ओनली 14 टू 15 स्टूडेंट्स ओनली नो इशू ऐसा
रहा तो मैं
फिर इस कोर्स को पूरे साल तक चलाऊंगा फुल
वन ईयर आई विल टेक वन ईयर टू कंप्लीट दिस
कोर्स बिकॉज़ इट इज अ फ्री आपका एक भी पैसे
नहीं लग रहे बट इसमें सबसे ज्यादा जो चीज
लग रही है वह वैल्यू ऐड हो रही है और
वैल्यू के साथसाथ मेरा टाइम
इस कोर्स में सबसे ज्यादा टाइम जा रहा है
मेरा। तो इस कोर्स को डिलीवर करने के बजाय
मैं फ्री में कहीं
पर बिल्कुल थोड़े से पैसों में भी
पढ़ाऊंगा तो तब भी मेरे पास आपसे ज्यादा
लोग आएंगे और अदरवाइज मैं अपना और कुछ
पर्सनल टाइम यूटिलाइजेशन करूंगा तो सबसे
बढ़िया रहेगा आप लोगों के टाइम मैं वेस्ट
करने के बजाय।
हाई5 में 4GB वाले रैम के लैपटॉप से क्या
कर लोगे? कुछ नहीं कर सकते। नथिंग यू कैन
नॉट डू
इट। और आपको सीखना ही है तो आपके लिए सबसे
बेस्ट चीजें चल तो रही है जीरो टू
इंटरमीडिएट तक और आपका फिर भी यही सवाल
आता रहता है। तो आई थिंक कि आप लोग
या हां मैं भी सोच रहा हूं इस कोर्स को
पेड कर दूंगा तो बेटर
रहेगा तो वो मेरे लिए बहुत अच्छा ऑप्शन
रहेगा क्योंकि मेरा तो टाइम वेस्ट ही हो
रहा है इधर
थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं स्टूडेंट्स के आने
का। देयर
ओनली चैट में 20 स्टूडेंट्स शो कर रहा है
बट अदरवाइज ओके 22
ओके 20
स्टूडेंट्स तो हां आई एम थिंकिंग कि इस
कोर्स को
थोड़ा पोज करने की सोच रहा हूं मैं आई एम
थिंकिंग बिकॉज़
इतने में मैं तो क्या कर लूंगा क्योंकि आई
एम वेस्टिंग माय
टाइम फॉर यू गाइस क्योंकि जिसको सीखना है
वो पैसे देके कहीं भी सीखेगा और जिसको
नहीं सीखना है तो आप उसको कितना ही पकड़
के सिखा लो वो नहीं सीखेंगे
50 वाला है उसको ही बढ़ा दीजिए। आई डोंट
नो कि आप क्या कहना चाहते हो। पल्लव
नहीं मेंबर ओनली करके मैं YouTube को पैसा
क्यों दूंगा?
डाउट क्लास रखने के लिए आपके डाउट तो होते
ही
नहीं। आदा आप में मैं तो पहली बार आपको
देखा है। आपका असली नाम क्या है? बॉय आई
डोंट
नो
प्लीज चलो सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं। फिर
वी विल नॉट वेस्ट आवर टाइम। छोटा सा सेशन
है उसको कंप्लीट करते हैं। ओके? तो आज का
जो हमारा टॉपिक है वो है आपका रिलेटेड टू
द Windows रजिस्ट्री। Windows रजिस्ट्री
के बारे में जो कुछ फंडामेंटल कांसेप्ट है
मैं आपको बताऊंगा क्योंकि इट इज आल्सो
वेरीेंट फॉर योर पेन टेस्टिंग जर्नी। खास
करके जब आप आगे बढ़ोगे तब क्योंकि आप कहीं
पर भी अगर फंडामेंटल्स देखोगे इवन ट्राई
हैक मी पर भी देखोगे तो जो Windows के
फंडामेंटल्स में है ये चीजें नहीं है कि
Windows रजिस्ट्री डीएलएल बस जस्ट एक
डेफिनेशन है और बेसिक बताया कि ये स्टार्ट
होता है। यह टास्क मैनेजर होता है। एट्रा
ये सारी चीजें होती हैं। मैं जस्ट आपकी
रिसर्च के लिए एक बार देखने वाला था। बट
आप एक काम कीजिए गो थ्रू कर लीजिए। आप अगर
एक और भी ज्यादा आपको अच्छे
से वो करना है तो ट्राई हैग्नी पे जाइए
हमें बीबी दे आर द फ्री फ्री लैब तो वहां
पर आप क्या कर सकते हो एटलीस्ट एटलीस्ट और
भी थोड़ा सा अगर बिल्कुल ही आपको नॉलेज
नहीं है तो आप क्या कर सकते
हो आप इन लैब्स को करके सॉल्व कर सकते हो
ओके यह रहा अब क्या कर सकते हो गो टू लर्न
टैब एंड सर्च यहां पर जाओगे विंडोज
फंडामेंट देखो Windows फंडामेंटल वन,
फंडामेंटल टू और फंडामेंटल थ्री। देखो ये
ध्यान से देखिए। Windows फंडामेंटल वन,
Windows फंडामेंटल टू और Windows
फंडामेंटल थ्री को पढ़ लीजिए। ये काफी
हेल्पफुल रहेगा आपके लिए। ओके? काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक्स हैं इनके अंदर भी। आप
इनको पढ़ सकते हैं। जैसे Windows
फंडामेंटल्स में क्या आ जाता है? जस्ट ये
तो बहुत ही बेसिक है। नाउ देखिए Windows
एडिशन क्या होते हैं? जीयूआई क्या होता
है? क्या किसका क्या मतलब होता है? मतलब
इसको ऑपरेट कैसे करते हैं Windows को?
उससे रिलेटेड आपका फंडामेंटल्स है।
बिल्कुल आप बिल्कुल न्यू बेबी हो। आपको
कुछ भी नहीं पता है तो यू कैन टेक इट।
यूएससी क्या होता है? और कैसे इसको एक्सेस
किया जाता है या कैसे इसका क्या रोल होता
है। तो ये सारी चीजें हैं बिल्कुल बेसिक।
यू कैन डू इट। और देयर आर थ्री Windows
फंडामेंटल वन, Windows फंडामेंटल टू,
Windows फंडामेंटल थ्री। देयर आर थ्री
बेसिक लैब्स दैट यू कैन डू इट योरसेल्फ।
तो शायद यह मुझे करवाने की आवश्यकता नहीं
होनी चाहिए क्योंकि दे आर वेरी वेरी वेरी
बेसिक और अगर आपको यह भी नहीं आता तो एक
बार गो थ्रू कीजिए तो आप आराम से अगले 2
घंटे में Windows के बारे में नॉलेज ले
लोगे तो ये आप कर सकते हो तो आज हम
Windows रजिस्ट्री के बारे में पढ़ने वाले
हैं। Windows रजिस्ट्री होती क्या है? और
दे आर ओके। अभी स्टूडेंट्स छोड़ के चले गए
जैसे Windows रजिस्ट्री का नाम आया। तो
मुझे मोटिवेट करने के लिए मत आइए। बिकॉज़
मुझे पता है कौन किस पर्पस से आता है
क्लास में और किस पर्पस से नहीं आता। तो
इट्स ओके। कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। हम इस
कोर्स को इतना स्लो पढ़ाएंगे, इतना स्लो
पढ़ाएंगे। ठीक है? मैं देखता हूं कि आप
कितने दिन तक नहीं आओगे। हम इस कोर्स को
बिल्कुल मैं अपनी मर्जी से पढ़ाऊंगा। आपको
अपनी मर्जी से पढ़िए और मैं भी अपनी मर्जी
से ही पढ़ाऊंगा। आई विल टेक टाइम। मैं कोई
फ्रीक्वेंटली क्लासेस नहीं लेने वाले बागे
से। तो सबसे पहले हम बात करते हैं कि
Windows रजिस्ट्री के बारे में। तो
Windows इज द ओनली ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हु यूज
द अप्रोच ऑफ रजिस्ट्री। Windows अकेला ऐसा
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है जो रजिस्ट्री को यूज
करता है। ओके? ऑल अदर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
लाइक iOS, Android, Linux
एसेट्रा कोई भी रजिस्ट्री को यूज़ नहीं
करता। अपने ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को कॉन्फ़िगर
करने के लिए और उसके बिहेवियर को मॉडिफाई
करने के लिए। ओनली Windows ही एक ऐसा
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है जो रजिस्ट्री की
अप्रोच को फॉलो करता है या रजिस्ट्री की
जो टेक्नोलॉजी या रजिस्टर डिजाइन किया है
अपने ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को कॉन्फ़िगर करने के
लिए रजिस्ट्री का ही यूज़ करता है। Windows
के अलावा कोई भी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम चाहे
आपका iOS है, चाहे Mac OS है, चाहे आपका
Android है, चाहे आपका Linux है, कोई भी
अपने ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को या उससे रिलेटेड
जो सेटिंग्स है, उनको कॉन्फ़िगर करने के
लिए रजिस्ट्री का यूज़ नहीं करता। मोस्ट ऑफ
द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम यूज़ द आईडिया ऑफ ए
टेक्स्ट फाइल फॉर कॉन्फ़िगरेशन ऑफ एवरीथिंग
लाइक वीडियो कार्ड, नेटवर्क प्रॉपर्टीज,
टीसीपी आईपी, फायर वाल रूल्स। सो एवरीथिंग
इज कॉन्फ़िगर बाय टेक्स्ट फाइल। बाकी सारे
के सारे ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम क्या है?
मैक्सिमम जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है, अपने
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को कॉन्फ़िगर करने के लिए
या आपके चाहे नेटवर्क प्रॉपर्टीज है, उसके
अंदर टीसीपी, आईपी की प्रॉपर्टीज है, चाहे
आपके फायर वाल रूल्स हैं, चाहे आपका
वीडियो कार्ड है। हर एक को कॉन्फ़िगर करने
के लिए वो क्या करते हैं? टेक्स्ट फाइल्स
का यूज करते हैं। हर एक तीन जो Windows के
अलावा सारे ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम क्या है?
टेक्स्ट आस्का टेक्स्ट फाइल का यूज़ करते
हैं कॉन्फ़िगर करने के लिए अपने सिस्टम्स
को कॉन्फ़िगर करने के लिए। सो इन द वर्ल्ड
ऑफ गाइस होल्ड
ऑन द वन
ओके आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट एवरीवन हेलो आई एम
ऑडिबल हेलो एवरीवन आई एम ऑडिबल
हेलो हेलो हेलो एवरीवन सबको सुनाई दे रहा
है तो मैंने माइक म्यूट किया था आई वाज ऑन
अ कॉलेंट कॉल ओके चलो ओके ओके ओके वी कैन
कंटिन्यू इट तो मैं आपको बता रहा था सो इन
द वर्ल्ड ऑफ़ लinक्स और अदर ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम जो आस्का टेक्स्ट फाइल्स हैं आर
हिडन फ्रॉम व्यू बिकॉज़ दे आर क्रिटिकल
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स। ओके? दे आर क्रिटिकल
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स।
तो जो मतलब मैं आपको क्या बताया था? आई एम
सॉरी फॉर दैट। आई लेट माय टॉपिक। ओके?
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम क्या करता है?
आपके रजिस्ट्री की अप्रोच को फॉलो करता है
आपके ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को कॉन्फ़िगर करने के
लिए या उसकी जो सिस्टम की सेटिंग है या
आपका कोई भी सेटिंग्स है, उसको कॉन्फ़िगर
करने के लिए। बाकी जितने भी ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम्स हैं, वो क्या करते हैं? आस्का
टेक्स्ट फाइल का यूज़ करते हैं अपनी
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को कॉफ़िगर करने के लिए।
लेकिन जो टेक्स्ट फाइल होती है यह आपके
सिस्टम में हाइड कर दी जाती है। आपको
नॉर्मली देखने को नहीं मिलती। उसको आपको
एक स्पेशल कमांड होती है। जैसे लinक्स की
बात को एलएस हफन एल करते हो तो तब डॉट डॉट
के साथ जो हिडन फाइल्स आपको देखने को
मिलती है। तो सम टाइम्स वो जैसे कि बेस आर
से कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल होती है। इसी प्रकार
से बहुत सारी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स होती
हैं। तो इसी प्रकार से Microsoft डिसाइडेड
टू गो डिफरेंट अप्रोच। तो कहने का मतलब ये
है कि Microsoft ने अ सब कॉमन अप्रोच फॉलो
करने के बजाय उन्होंने क्या है? एक
डिफरेंट अप्रोच का यूज किया अपने ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम को कॉन्फ़िगर करने के लिए जिसको हम
बोलते हैं रजिस्ट्री। वो सारे के सारे काम
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम में कोई भी कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस
हो, चाहे किसी भी लेवल के कॉन्फ़िगरेशन की
सेटिंग हो, सबको रजिस्ट्री के थ्रू ही
क्या करता है? डील करता है। रजिस्ट्री के
थ्रू ही कॉन्फ़िगर करता है। ओके? तो, व्हाट
इज द Windows रजिस्ट्री? अब ये Windows
रजिस्ट्री होती क्या है? Windows
रजिस्ट्री इज ए कॉम्प्लेक्स हेरिकल
डेटाबेस इन Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स। अब
दैट स्टोर लो लेवल सेटिंग्स फॉर द
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स एंड एप्लीकेशनेशंस। जब
Windows रजिस्ट्री होती है वो क्या है? एक
कॉम्प्लेक्स हेरारिकल डेटाबेस है Windows
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर। जो क्या करता
है? जो भी आपका ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स है,
उसकी जितनी भी सेटिंग्स है या जो भी
एप्लीकेशनेशंस है, सबकी जो भी सेटिंग्स
है, या कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस है, सबको क्या करता
है? स्टोर करके रखता है और इट प्लेज़ अ
वेरी क्रिटिकल रोल्स इन सिस्टम
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन, सॉफ्टवेयर सेटिंग, यूजर
प्रेफरेंसेस एंड मोर। ओके? तो अभी हेरिकल
डेटाबेस का क्या मतलब होता है? हेरिकल
डेटाबेस को हम बोल सकते हैं एक ट्रे की
स्ट्रक्चर की फॉर्म में। जैसे ट्रे की
स्ट्रक्चर सबको पता है। शाखाएं बहुत सारी।
उसी प्रकार से आजकल जो रजिस्ट्री है,
रजिस्ट्री भी क्या है? एक हरिकल डेटाबेस
है। वो ट्रे स्ट्रक्चर को फॉलो करती है
अपने
डाटा के अंदर इंफॉर्मेशन को स्टोर करने के
लिए करेंटली हरारिकल डेटाबेस आर स्टिल
वाइडली यूज्ड स्पेशली इन एप्लीकेशनेशंस
दैट रिक्वायर वेरी हाई परफॉर्मेंस एंड
अवेलेबिलिटी सच एज बैंकिंग एंड टेलीकॉप्ट
आजकल क्या है कि परफॉर्मेंस के लिए
एप्लीकेशनेशंस की परफॉर्मेंस के लिए या
चाहे ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स हो या सॉफ्टवेयर
की परफॉर्मेंस के लिए सबसे ज्यादा आपके
हरारिकल या ट्रीस्ट्रक्चर डेटाबेस का यूज
किया जाता है। अभी इट इज़ अ डेटाबेस दैट इज़
डिज़ फॉर फास्ट रीड्स एंड राइट। यह वह
डेटाबेस है जिसको डिज़ किया गया है बहुत ही
फास्ट तरीके से रीड और राइट किया जा सके
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर। इट इज़ वेरी
एफिशिएंट स्टोरेज एंड द Windows रजिस्ट्री
टिपिकली रेंजेस फ्रॉम 400 MB टू 1.5 GB ऑन
मॉडर्न Windows सिस्टम्स। अभी एफिशिएंट
स्टोरेज का मतलब क्या है? कि इस जो
रजिस्ट्री का जो सारी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
सेटिंग्स है अब मॉडर्न Windows के केस में
बात करें वो 400 MB से लेके 1 1/2 GB तक
के रेंज में रहता है। इसके बीच में क्या
है? इसका साइज होता है। एंड इट इज ऑलवेज
लोडेड इनू RAM एज ए बूट एज Windows बूट।
जैसे Windows आपका बूट करता है, यह सारे
की सारी जो कॉन्फ़िगरेशन है, जो रजिस्ट्री
का डेटा आपके RAM के अंदर क्या कर दिया
जाता है? लोड कर दिया जाता है। दैट इज़
व्हाई इट इज़ अ वेरी एफिशिएंट स्टोरेज एंड
इट इज़ वेरी फास्ट फॉर रीड्स एंड राइट्स।
रजिस्ट्री इज़ स्टर्ड ऑन द हार्ड ड्राइव।
रजिस्ट्री आपकी हार्ड ड्राइव के ऊपर स्टोर
रहती है। एंड एनी टाइम वी स्टोर ए
रजिस्ट्री पोर्शन ऑन द हार्ड डिस्क इट इज
कॉल्ड ए हाइव। अभी हम रजिस्टर को हार्ड
डिस्क के ऊपर जिस जगह पर स्टोर करते हैं,
उस जगह हम जगह को हम क्या बोलते हैं? उस
जगह को बोलते हैं हम हाईव। उस जगह को क्या
बोलते हैं? हाइव। अगर कोई बोलता है कि ओके
दैट इज द लोकेशन जहां पर आपकी रजिस्ट्री
स्टर्ड है तो उस लोकेशन को हम बोलेंगे
हाइव। तो द रजिस्ट्री कंटेन टू बेसिक
एलिमेंट्स। अब जो रजिस्ट्रीज है इसके अंदर
बेसिकली दो एलिमेंट्स होते हैं। कीज़ और
वैल्यू जो जो भी डाटा स्टोर होती है ये
कीज़ और वैल्यू की फॉर्म में स्टोर करती
है।
रजिस्ट रजिस्ट्री कीज़ आर कंटेनर ऑब्जेक्ट
सिमिलर टू फोल्डर्स। अभी क्या है कि जो
रजिस्ट्री कीज़ को आप फोल्डर के की तरह बोल
सकते हो। दे आर लाइक ए फोल्डर नॉट ए
फोल्डर। फोल्डर नहीं है लेकिन सिमिलर टू
फोल्डर। आप अज्यूम कर सकते हो समझने के
लिए। वैल्यूज आर नॉन कंटेनर ऑब्जेक्ट
सिमिलर टू फाइल्स। वैल्यू्यूज को आप बोल
सकते हैं फाइल्स बट वो फाइल्स नहीं होती।
उसकी तरह ही होती है। लेकिन वो फाइल्स
नहीं होती। बस आपको एग्जांपल के लिए की को
आप समझ सकते हो फोल्डर और वैल्यू को समझ
सकते हो फाइल्स। फोल्डर के अंदर फाइल्स। द
रजिस्ट्री सेव ऑल डेटा इन बाइनरी फॉर्म
फॉर स्पीड एंड मेमोरी एफिशिएंट। और
रजिस्ट्री ये सारी की सारी जो सेटिंग्स है
उसका जो डेटा है वो किसकी फॉर्म में सेव
करती है? बाइनरी की फॉर्म में। ताकि जो
आपकी अपलोडिंग रीड और राइट स्पीड है वो
काफी हाई हो। ठीक है? मेमोरी एफिशिएंट हो।
तो दैट इज कॉल्ड Windows रजिस्ट्री। सबको
समझ में आई? Windows रजिस्ट्री होता क्या
है? एक्चुअल में एवरीवन
ओके एवरीवन प्लीज
आंसर दीजिए। सबको समझ में आया कि
रजिस्ट्री होती क्या है?
ओके। नाउ
अभी देयर आर फाइव रूट कीज़। अब जो
रजिस्ट्रीज है आपके Windows के अंदर इस
तरीके से देखने को मिलती है। अभी जो इनकी
मेन क्या है? ये फाइव रूट कीज़ होती है।
मेन तो जो है यह फाइव टाइप्स की होती है।
देखो ट्री स्ट्रक्चर की फॉर्म में होती
है। तो डायरेक्टली जैसे ही आप रजिस्ट्री
एडिटर ओपन करोगे अपने सिस्टम के अंदर
डायरेक्टली कितनी होती है? ओनली इनकी जो
रूट कीज़ जिनको बोल सकते हैं इसके अंदर ये
क्या है? सब कीज़ हैं। उनके अंदर फिर और सब
कीज़ हैं। तो बेसिकली ये फाइव रूट कीज़ होती
है रजिस्ट्री की। अब इनके अंदर देयर आर
लॉट ऑफ़ सब कीज़। देयर आर मिलियंस ऑफ सब
कीज़। ओके? मिलियंस ऑफ। ठीक है? इतनी
ज्यादा बड़ी अमाउंट में इसके अंदर
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन सेटिंग्स हैं। तब इनको वन बाय
वन समझेंगे। अगर मैं आपको दिखाऊं तो आपको
कैसे मिलेगा? डायरेक्टली आपको क्या करना
है? विंडो आर और रेज एडिट हिट एंटर। यह
आपका रजिस्ट्री एडिटर्स है। एंड आई क्लोज
इट। तो ये देखिए मैं एक काम करता हूं। दे
दीज़ आर द फाइव रूट कीज़। एच की क्लासेस
रूट, एच की करंट यूजर, एच की लोकल मशीन,
एच की यूजर्स और एच की करंट कंटिंग। दीज़
ऑल आर द फाइव्स रूट कीज़ ऑफ योर रजिस्ट्री।
रूट की इसलिए बोला गया क्योंकि पूरा का
पूरा जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम जो कॉन्फ़िगरर्ड
किया गया है, या जितने भी आपकी सिस्टम
सेटिंग है या कोई भी कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस है, कोई
भी सेटिंग आपका जो फोंट साइज है, आपका
डेस्कटॉप इमेज है, व्हाटएवर द सेटिंग्स वो
सारी की सारी क्या है? इन फाइव रूट कीज़ के
अंडर ही आती है। ओके?
बिल्कुल है। अगली हम बात करते हैं सबसे
पहले एचकी एलएम एच की लोकल मशीन की की। यह
रहा एच की लोकल मशीन के बारे में जानते
हैं। दिस इज द मोस्ट क्रिटिकल रजिस्ट्री
की फ्रॉम ऑल कीज़। सबसे क्रिटिकल रजिस्ट्री
फी है। सबसेेंट रजिस्ट्री कीज़ है यह। दी
एचके लोकल मशीन जिसको हम एचके एलएमबी
बोलते हैं। हाई इन द विंडोज रिस्टोर
सिस्टम वाइड सेटिंग्स एंड कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस
दैट अप्लाई टू ऑल यूज़र्स ऑन अ कंप्यूटर।
इसके अंदर वो सारी सेटिंग्स जो
कॉन्फ़िगरेशनंस होती है जो आपके पीसी के
ऊपर सभी यूज़र्स के ऊपर अप्लाई होती है।
एचकेएलएम होल्ड सिस्टम क्रिटिकल डेटा
इंक्लूडिंग इंस्टॉल सॉफ्टवेयर, हार्डवेयर
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस, ड्राइवर्स, सिक्योरिटी
पॉलिसीज एंड बूट सेटिंग। चाहे आपकी
हार्डवेयर की कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस हो, चाहे जो भी
सॉफ्टवेयर इंस्टॉल किया गया उसकी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस हो, चाहे ड्राइवर्स की
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन हो, चाहे सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसीज
हो, चाहे आपकी बूट की सेटिंग्स हो, सारी
की सारी क्या है? इसके अंदर इसके अंदर
देखने को मिलेगी आपको एचकेएलएम एच की लोकल
मशीन के अंदर। ओके? इसके अंदर टोटल सिक्स
सब कीज़ होती हैं। ओल्ड वाली सिस्टम्स
होंगे उसमें सेवन देखने को मिलेंग। लेकिन
लेटेस्ट वालों में अभी Windows 11 के अंदर
आपको सिक्स सब कीज़ देखने को मिलेंगी। ओके?
अभी इनके बारे में हम बस इंट्रोडक्शन
लेंगे और एज ए पेंटस्टर्स हमारे लिए कौन
सी इंपॉर्टेंट है? तो किस टाइप का उसके पर
अटैक परफॉर्म हो सकता है। बस्ट वो हम
देखने वाले हैं। तो सबसे पहले हम बात करते
हैं एच की लोकल मशीन सिस्टम। ये वाली एच
की लोकल मशीन सिस्टम लास्ट वाली। तो एचके
लोकल मशीन सिस्टम के अंदर बात करते हैं।
दी एचके लोकल मशीन सिस्टम एचकेएलएम सिस्टम
हाईव इन द विंडो रजिस्ट्री इज कंटेन
सिस्टम वाइज सेटिंग्स दैट कंट्रोल
हार्डवेयर ड्राइवर्स सर्विसेज नेटवर्किंग
एंड बूट कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस। अभी जो एचके अलम है
उसके अंदर और भी द मोस्ट क्रिटिकल जो सब
कीज़ है वो कौन सी है? आपकी सिस्टम की।
इसके अंदर होते हैं आपके हार्डवेयर से
रिलेटेड, ड्राइवर से रिलेटेड, सर्विज से
रिलेटेड या नेटवर्किंग या बूट कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
रिलेटेड आपकी सेटिंग्स होती हैं। अबकी की
फंक्शनैलिटी क्या है? इट स्टोर सिस्टम
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन दैट अप्लाई टू ऑल यूज़र्स।
कंट्रोल ड्राइवर्स, Windows सर्विज,
सिस्टम स्टार्टअप में सेटिंग। यह क्या
करता है? आपके ड्राइवर्स को कंट्रोल करता
है। Windows की सर्विज को कंट्रोल करती
है। और सिस्टम स्टार्टअप सेटिंग को मैनेज
नेटवर्क कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस, पावर सेटिंग्स एंड
डिवाइस मैपिंग। यह क्या करता है? आपके
नेटवर्क सेटिंग को भी मैनेज करता है। उसके
पावर से रिलेटेड और डिवाइस की मैपिंग भी
इसी से थ्रू की जैसे माउंट्स के अंदर
इंक्लूड मल्टीपल बैकअप कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फॉर
रिकवरी पर्पज। एज ए पटेस्टर द एचके लोकल
मशीन सिस्टम हाइव इज क्रूशियल फॉर
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन पर्सिस्टेंस
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग एंड नेटवर्क
रिकॉनसेंस। अभी प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन करना
हो, चाहे आपको पर्सिस्टेंस करना हो, चाहे
आपको क्रेडेंशियल डंप करने हो, चाहे आपको
नेटवर्क रिकॉनसेंस करनी हो। सभी के केस
में आप क्या करते हो? करते हो इस पे
ज्यादा फोकस करते हो। खास कर कि Windows
के केस में आपको रजिस्ट्री पे रीड राइट
परमिशंस मिलती है एज ए यूज़र्स किसी भी
यूज़र्स के रूप में। तो आप फिर आपके लिए
क्या है? एक गोल्डन अप्रोच होती है। तो
बिलो आर द मोस्टेंट रजिस्ट्री कीज़ दैट
अटैकर्स एंड डिफेंडर्स सच फोकस होना। ठीक
है? कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट रजिस्ट्री कॉमन
रजिस्ट्री इन्हीं के अंदर इनके अंदर जिसके
बारे में हम डिस्कस करने वाले हैं। ओके?
तो सबसे पहली आती है एचकेएलएम सिस्टम करंट
कंट्रोल सेट कंट्रोल उसके अंदर सिक्योरिटी
प्रोवाइडर्स देखो एचकेएलएम की सबकी क्या
है सिस्टम सिस्टम की सबकी करंट कंट्रोल
सेट आगे मैं बैक में ये रही करंट कंट्रोल
सेट थर्ड नंबर पे उसके बाद उसके अंदर
कंट्रोल उसके अंदर सिक्योरिटी प्रोवाइडर्स
अभी जो एचकेएलएम सिस्टम करंट कंट्रोल सेट
है जो सिक्योरिटी प्रोवाइडर रजिस्ट्री की
है मैनेज सिक्योरिटी ऑथेंटिकेशन प्रोवाइडर
यूज्ड बाय द Windows अभी जब भी आप क्या
करते हो? Windows के अंदर लॉगिन करते हो
तो उसकी
सिक्योरिटी को भी कोई ना कोई मैनेज करता
है। अब उसकी सिक्योरिटी प्रोवाइडर
ऑथेंटिकेशन जो प्रोवाइडर्स है Windows की
उसकी जो इंफॉर्मेशन है इस की के अंदर
स्टोर होती है। दिस इंक्लूड्स मैकेनिज्म
लाइक करोस एनtएलएम डाइजेस्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन
एंड सिक्योर चैनल कि जो मेरा Windows
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स है जब मैं लॉगिन करूंगा
या मेरे कोई भी सर्विज अब किसी भी अकाउंट
को यूज़ करेगी तो वो ऑथेंटिकेशन के लिए कौन
से मैकेनिज्म का यूज़ करेगी क्या वो प्लेन
टेक्स्ट का यूज़ करेगी या करबोस का यूज़
करेगी एनtएलएम का यूज़ करेगी या डाइजेस्ट
ऑथेंटिकेशन या सिक्योर चैनल इनमें से कौन
से मैकेनिज्म का यूज़ करेगी व्हाट इज द
कीेंट ऑफ़ पेन टेस्टिंग अब प निट्रेशन
टेस्टर के लिए सबसेेंट पॉइंट क्या है यहां
पर? अटैकर्स कैन इंजेक्ट मशियस डीएलएल्स
इंटू द ऑथेंटिकेशन प्रोसेस। अभी जो ये
ऑथेंटिकेशन प्रोसेस है इसके अंदर क्या कर
सकता है? अपना खुद का कोई मशियस डीएलएल
फाइल है या ट्रोजन बोल सकते हो या
मालवेयर्स बोल सकते हो उसको इंजेक्ट कर
सकता है। एंड कैन बी यूज़्ड टू स्टील
क्रेडेंशियल्स एट लॉग इन। लॉगिन करते वक्त
ही उसके क्रेडेंशियल को क्या कर सकता है?
स्टील कर सकता है, चुरा कर चुरा सकता है।
ऑफन एक्सप्लइटेड बाय क्रेडेंशियल
हार्वेस्टिंग मालवेयर लाइक मिमीज। अभी
मिमीज का किसी ने नाम सुना हो तो अच्छी
बात है। नहीं भी सुना होगा तो हम यूज़ करके
दिखाएंगे क्लासेस के अंदर। तो अब मिमीज
क्या है? काफी पॉपुलर टूल्स होता है जो
Windows के केस में आपका काफी खतरनाक टूल
है। मतलब उससे बहुत सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आपको
देखने को मिलती है। तो उस जैसे टूल को भी
उस जैसा टूल भी क्या करता है? यही काम
करता है। अगर इस तरह की कोई इंफॉर्मेशन
मिलती है तो इनके अंदर भी Windows यूजज़ ए
लिस्ट ऑफ सिक्योरिटी सपोर्ट प्रोवाइडर्स
एसएसपी जो बोलते हैं टू ऑथेंटिकेट यूज़र्स।
अभी Windows क्या करती है कि यूज़र्स को
ऑथेंटिकेट करने के लिए कुछ सिक्योरिटी
सपोर्ट प्रोवाइडर्स होती है उनका यूज़ करती
है। जो डिफॉल्ट सिक्योरिटी प्रोवाइडर्स
हैं वो आपको कहां पे स्टोर होता है? इस सब
की के अंदर सिक्योरिटी प्रोवाइडर्स। इसके
अंदर कौन-कौन सी वैल्यू देखने को आप मिल
सकती है? एमएस एपीएसएस पीसी.L
[संगीत]
स्कैनल डीएl डजस्टl
एमएसएसपीसीl क्रेड एसएसpdl नॉर्मली आपके
शायद क्रेड एसएसपीl देखने को मिलेगी आपके
सिक्योरिटी प्रोवाइडर के अंदर जो वैल्यू
देखने को मिलेगी यह देखने को मिलेगी
रजिस्ट्री की के अंदर दीज़ डीएलएल
डीएलएसल्स हैंडल्स वेरियस ऑथेंटिकेशन
मैकेनिज्म अटैकर्स अपेंड ए मशियस डीएल टू
दिस लिस्ट टू अ कैप्चर क्रेडेंशियल अब ये
क्या है कि अटैकर्स क्या कर सकता है यही
यहीं पर अपनी जो मिलेशियस डीआरएल को अटैच
कर सकता है। उस वैल्यू को चेंज कर सकता
है। अगर यहां पर उसको राइट एक्सेस मिल गया
और जैसे ही आप का सिस्टम बूट करेगा लॉग इन
टाइम पे ही वो क्या कर सकता है? आपके
क्रेडेंशियल्स को थप्ट कर सकता है। डंप कर
सकता है। फाइंड आउट कर सकता है। ओके? तो
सेकंड पॉइंट है आपके जो है एचकेएलएम
सिस्टम करंट कंट्रोल सेंट के अंदर सर्विज
होती है जो थर्ड जो सेकंड सब कीज़ होती है
द एचकेएलएम सिस्टम करंट कंट्रोल सेट
सर्विज रजिस्ट्री की कंट्रोल्स विंडोज
सर्विज कल प्रीवियस क्लास थी हमने सर्विज
के बारे में पढ़ा था तो उसकी जो सर्विज की
इनेशन इस रजिस्ट्री की के अंदर देखने को
मिलती है ओके तो ये रजिस्ट्री की है
सर्विस से रिलेटेड व्हिच स्टार्ट
ऑटोमेटिकली व्हेन द सिस्टम बूट इफ इफ एन
अटैकर मॉडिफाई अ सर्विस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन दे
कैन अचीव पर्सिस्टेंस प्रिलज एस्केलेशन
एंड एग्जीक्यूट मिलिशियस पेलोड ऑन रिमूट।
ओके समझ में आया कि अगर अटैकर्स को कोई भी
यहां पर मिसकॉन्फ़िगर सर्विस मिलती है तो
अटैकर क्या कर सकता है? उस सर्विस को
मॉडिफाई करके यहां पर प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
या पर्सिस्टेंस जैसे अटैक परफॉर्म कर सकता
है। जैसे आपका सिस्टम रिबूूट कर रिबूूट
करेगा। ओके से थर्ड पॉइंट जो एचकेएलएम
सिस्टम करंट कंट्रोल सेट कंट्रोल एलएसए
एलएसए का नाम सुना होगा एलएसए क्या है
आपका क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग प्रोटेक्शन के
लिए यूज़ किया जाता है उसको हम बायपास भी
कर सकते हैं अगर यहां पर परमिशंस मिलती है
तो व्हाट इज द एलएसए रजिस्ट्री की एलएसए
रजिस्ट्री की होती क्या है दी एलएसए
स्टैंड फॉर लोकल सिक्योरिटी अथॉरिटी इज ए
क्रिटिकल विंडोज कंपोनेंट रिस्पांसिबल फॉर
हैंडलिंग सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसीज ऑथेंट
एंड क्रेडेंशियल मैनेजमेंट। अभी जो एलएसए
होता है एक क्रिटिकल विंडोज कंपोनेंट है
जो क्या है कि आपके सिस्टम की सिक्योरिटी
पॉलिसीज को उसकी ऑथेंटिकेशन पॉलिसी को या
क्रेडेंशियल को मैनेज करता है या इंश्योर
करता है द यूज़र्स एंड सर्विज आर प्रॉपर्ली
ऑथेंटिकेटेड बिफोर एक्सेसिंग सिस्टम
रिसोर्सेज। कोई भी सर्विज हो चाहे कोई भी
यूज़र्स हो अगर वो सिस्टम के रिसोर्सेज को
एक्सेस करना चाहता है तो प्रॉपर्ली
ऑथेंटिकेट होना चाहिए। व्हाटएवर द मीडियम
यहां पर जो प्रोवाइड किया गया है की
रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज क्या है एलएसए की इट
वैलिडेट्स यूजर लॉगिस वाया पासवर्ड
स्मार्ट कार्ड्स या बायोमेट्रिक्स मैनेज
ऑथेंटिकेशन प्रोटोकॉल लाइक करबोस एंटीएलएम
डाइजेस्ट इनफोर्स लोकल सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसीज
पासवर्ड पॉलिसीज या रिस्ट्रिकशंस कितने
टाइम से रॉन्ग पासवर्ड भर सकते हो उसके
बाद आपका अकाउंट ब्लॉक कर दिया जाएगा
स्टोर सिक्योरिटी सीक्रेट्स इन मेमोरी
जैसे पासवर्ड्स हैंज़ हैं एक्सेस टोकंस हैं
लॉक सिक्योरिटी रिलेटेड ेड इवेंट टू द
Windows इवेंट लॉक। और Windows इवेंट लॉक
के अंदर क्या है? सिक्योरिटी रिलेटेड जो
लॉक्स है उनको लॉक करना। इफ कंप्रोमाइज
अटैक इफ कंप्रोमाइज अगर इसको कंप्रोमाइज
कर लिया गया एलएसए को। अटैकर क्या कर सकता
है? स्टिल क्रेडेंशियल्स एस्केलेट
प्रिविलजेस और डिसेबल सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसीज।
और सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसीज को डिसेबल भी कर
सकता है। बिकॉज़ दिस रजिस्ट्री की कंटेंस
क्रिटिकल सिक्योरिटी सेटिंग्स व्हिच
डिफाइन हाउ ऑथेंटिकेशन एंड क्रेडेंशियल
मैनेजमेंट वर्क। जो यह डिफाइन करता है कि
जो आपका ऑथेंटिकेशन है वो क्रेडेंशियल
मैनेजमेंट कैसे काम करता है। अगर इसका
इसको कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लिया आपके अटैकर्स
ने तो क्या कर सकता है? वो काफी पावरफुल
अटैक परफॉर्म कर सकता है। तो यहां तक सबको
क्लियर है? किसी को कोई डाउट है?
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है?
नेक्स्ट स्लाइड में चल। ओके जो फोर्थ नंबर
पे जो हमारी सबकी आती है एचकेएलएम सिस्टम
के अंदर करंट कंट्रोल सेट के अंदर कंट्रोल
एंड टर्मिनल नाम से आपको देखने को मिलती
है। द टर्मिनल सर्वर रजिस्ट्री की डिफाइन
हाउ रिमोट डेस्कटॉप प्रोटोकॉल बक्स। अब जो
आरडीपी से रिलेटेड जो सेटिंग्स है
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस आपको इसके अंदर देखने को
मिलती है विंडो सिस्टम के ऊपर दे कंट्रोल
आरडीपी सेशन लिमिट्स इंक्रिप्शन
ऑथेंटिकेशन एंड रिमोट कंट्रोल दी टर्मिनल
सर्वर रजिस्ट्री सेटिंग इन Windows
कंट्रोल इन Windows कंट्रोल रिमोट
डेस्कटॉप प्रोटोकॉल कॉन्फ़िगरेशनंस। अभी जो
यह जो रजिस्ट्री कीज़ है, यह आपकी आरडीपी
की कॉन्फ़िगरेशनंस को क्या करती है?
कंट्रोल करती है, मैनेज करती है। अटैकर्स
कैन मॉडिफाई दीज़ सेटिंग्स फॉर आरडीपी
पर्सिस्टेंस, ऑथेंटिकेशन, बाईपास और सेशन
हाईजैकिंग जैसी चीजें परफॉर्म करने के लिए
भी अटैकर्स इसका यूज़ कर सकते हैं। बट मैं
आपको लास्ट में बताऊंगा कि जितना इजीली
मैं आपको बता रहा हूं कि अटैकर यह कर सकते
हैं। दैट इज नॉट सो इजी। ओके? क्योंकि
Windows रजिस्ट्री को हर कोई टच नहीं कर
सकता। इसके ऊपर भी आपके क्या होते हैं?
परमिशंस होती हैं। सबको परमिशंस नहीं
होती।
अभी फिफ्थ नंबर पर आता है आपके एचकेएलएम
सिस्टम सेटअप एचकेएलएम सिस्टम सेटअप की द
एचकेएलएम सिस्टम सेटअप रजिस्ट्री की इज
क्रिटिकल ड्यूरिंग विंडोज इंस्टॉलेशन
अपडेट्स एंड रिकवरी ओके अटैकर्स कैन टपर
विद इट टू बायपास सिक्योरिटी सेटअप सेटअप
सिक्योरिटी मॉडिफाई सिस्टम बिहेवियर और
पर्सिस्ट अक्रॉस द रिब्स अभी क्या है कि
आपका जब भी कोई भी विंडो को इंस्टॉल करते
हो अपडेट करते हो रिकवरी करते हैं उससे
रिलेटेड जो भी कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस है। उससे
रिलेटेड जो भी सेटिंग्स है, वह इस
रजिस्ट्री की के अंदर होती हैं। अब
अटैकर्स चाहे अगर अटैकर्स यहां तक पहुंच
गया, तो इसको भी टपर कर सकता
है। सिक्स्थ नंबर पे आता है आपका एचकेएलएम
सिस्टम सेलेक्ट स्विचिंग कंट्रोल सेट।
ओके? मतलब सेलेक्ट के बाद यह रजिस्ट्री की
एचकेएलम सिस्टम सेलेक्ट। अभी मैं
आपको पागल नहीं बना रहा। अगर आपको लगता है
तो दी ज्यादा
देखो एचकेएलएम
सिस्टम करंट कंट्रोल सेट देखिए कंट्रोल के
अंदर दी ऑल आर द देखिए जो भी हमने बात की
होगी अभी शायद जो जो भी की है देखो आप
देखोगे यहां पर एलएसए ये देखो एलएसए एलएसए
ये रहा एलएस से रिलेटेड ये रही अगर
सिक्योरिटी वाली बात करता हूं मैं
सिक्योरिटी प्रोवाइडर देखो और भी चीजें
हैं देखो सिक्योरिटी ये रहा सिक्योरिटी
प्रोवाइडर सिक्योरिटी प्रोवाइडर के अंदर
एक वैल्यू देखो सिक्योरिटी प्रोवाइडर की
वैल्यू क्रेड एसएसpdl मेरी मर्जी मशीन का
यह है। ओके। तो, यहां पर कुछ भी आपको ऐसे
फुल नहीं है। ये सारी इनेशन यहीं से
देखिए। ये सारी वैल्यूज़ सेटअप होती है
आपकी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स
की। तो, अभी बात करते हैं एचकेएलएम सिस्टम
सेलेक्ट की। तो, एचकेएलएम सिस्टम सेलेक्ट
रजिस्ट्री की कंट्रोल्स वि सिस्टम
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस इज यूज्ड ड्यूरिंग Windows
स्टार्टअप। इट प्लेज़ ए क्रूशियल रोल इन
Windows बूट प्रोसेस, रिकवरी मैकेनिज्म
एंड पर्सिस्टेंट टेक्निक। अभी यहां पर जो
वैल्यू स्टोर होती है यहां पे आपकी करंट
कंट्रोल सेट एक विंडोज के अंदर मल्टीपल
करंट कंट्रोल सेट होते हैं। आपके सिस्टम्स
की कॉन्फ़िगरेशनंस होती है। खासकर की जो
आपके बूटिंग प्रोसेस के लिए आपके रिकवरी
के लिए और के लिए काफी इंपॉर्टेंट होती है
Windows के लिए। Windows मेंटेंस मल्टीपल
करंट कंट्रोल सेट इन द रजिस्ट्री। ईच
कंट्रोल सेट इज़ अ स्नैपशट ऑफ़ द सिस्टम
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस इंक्लूडिंग सर्विसेस,
ड्राइवर्स एंड सिक्योरिटी सेटिंग्स। यह
क्या एक स्नैपशॉट होता है। एक बैकअप टाइप
का होता है। ओके? अभी जब मैं Windows को
बूट करूंगा तो बूट करते वक्त मैं कौन सा
करंट कंट्रोल सेट यूज़ करूंगा? 0 1 02 या
00 यूज़ करूंगा। तो वो यहां पर डिफाइन रहता
है। ओके? जैसे मैं अपने केस में बताता
हूं। ये रहा। अभी तो मैंने बंद कर दिया
Windows रजिस्ट्री को Window R एडिट एंड
ओके
एंड वे द कंट्रोल एंड सिस्टम सेलेक्ट
सिस्टम सेलेक्ट। हम
हम
सिस्टम सिस्टम सेलेक्ट ये रहा देखिए
यहां पर क्या है ये बाइनरी वैल्यूज़ हैं।
ओके यहां पर बाइनरी वैल्यूज़ है। लेकिन
करंट कंट्रोल सेट देखोगे तो यहां पे देखो
जैसे करंट कंट्रोल सेट ज़ीरो वन ऐसे 02 ऐसे
अभी यहां पे देख कर कंट्रोल सेट तो ये
वाली सेटिंग्स यहां पर अवेलेबल रहती है।
मुझे किससे अपने सिस्टम को बूट करना है।
ओके अभी इसकी बात करते हैं। अगर आपके
अटैकर्स इसको सक्सेसफुली मैनपुलेट करने
में पॉसिबल हो पाए तो अटैकर्स कैन फोर्स
विंडोज़ टू बूट इनू ए बैकडोर्ड कंट्रोल सेट
दैट कंटेन मलेशियस ड्राइवर्स डिसेबल
सिक्योरिटी सेटिंग्स और अल्टर्ड
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन। यह अटैक तो बहुत ही खतरनाक
अटैक हो सकता है। बट 1% परसेंटेज ऑफ़
चांसेस टू पास दिस अटैक। ओके? क्योंकि यह
सारा कुछ करने के लिए आपको या तो कोई
मलेशियस ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम ही प्रोवाइड करना
पड़ेगा या फिर आपको फिजिकली एक्सेस लेना
होगा। ओके? फिजिकल अटैक का पार्ट आ जाता
है यह। नेक्स्ट एचके लोकल मशीन सेम। अभी
हम बात करते हैं लोकल मशीन के अंदर।
सिस्टम वाली बात तो खत्म हो गई। अभी आ गई
हमारी एचके लोकल मशीन सैम के अंदर क्या
होता है? द एचके लोकल मशीन सेम रजिस्ट्री
इन विंडोज इज वन ऑफ द मोस्ट सेंसिटिव
एरिया ऑफ़ द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम। ये सबसे
सेंसिटिव एरिया होता है आपके ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम का। इट कंटेंस इंक्रिप्टेड पासवर्ड
हैस, यूजर अकाउंट डेटा एंड सिक्योरिटी
रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन। अभी जो सेम डेटाबेस
आपने सुना होगा, तो यह वही रजिस्ट्री की
है जिसके अंदर आपके पासवर्ड हैज़, आपके
यूजर के अकाउंट की डिटेल्स या आपके
सिक्योरिटी से रिलेटेड जो भी इनेशन है,
इसी रजिस्ट्री की के अंदर क्फ़िगर रहती है।
डायरेक्ट एक्सेस टू दिस की इज़ हैवली
रिस्ट्रिक्टेड एंड एज इट प्लेज़ ए क्रूशियल
रोल इन सिस्टम ऑथेंटिकेशन। और सिस्टम
ऑथेंटिकेशन में सबसे ज्यादा अहम रोल यही
प्ले करती है। बट यह फुल्ली रिस्ट्रिक्टेड
है। इवन जो आपका एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स है उसको
भी अलाउ नहीं है। तो व्हाट इज सेम? सेम
क्या है? दी सिक्योरिटी अकाउंट मैनेजर इज
अ डेटाबेस दैट स्टोर्स लोकल यूजर अकाउंट
इनेशन इंक्लूडिंग यूजरनेम, सिक्योरिटी
आइडेंटिफायर्स, पासवर्ड हैस और अकाउंट
पॉलिसीज। ओके? ओके पासवर्ड कब एक्सपायर ये
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आपके इस डेटाबेस के अंदर
मेंटेन की जाती है। दिस डेटाबेस इज यूज्ड
बाय द लोकल सिक्योरिटी अथॉरिटी सब सिस्टम
जो एलसास प्रोसेस है उसके द्वारा इसको
मैनेज किया जाता है टू ऑथेंटिकेट यूज़र्स
व्हेन दे लॉग इन जब मैंने आपको बताया था
कि सेशन मैनेजर मैनेजमेंट होने के बाद जो
विन logon डॉट exc की जो प्रोसेस स्टार्ट
होती है साथ के साथ एलs exc प्रोसेस
स्टार्ट होती है तो वो यहां से डाटा उठाती
है विजुअल को ऑथेंटिकेट करने के लिए बाय
डिफॉल्ट इवन एन एडमिनिस्टर कैन नॉट ओपन
ओपन एच लोकल मशीन सेम इन रजिस्ट्री एडिटर
ड्यू टू सिक्योरिटी रेस्ट्रिकशंस आपको मैं
देखिए जब आप ओपन करने की कोशिश करोगे अपने
पीसी के अंदर कहां पर एचके लोकल मशीन और
सेम के अंदर तो आप इस तरीके से वैल्यू
देखने को मिलेगी वैल्यू नॉट सेट बट ऐसा
नहीं है क्योंकि Windows ने रिस्ट्रिक्ट
किया हुआ है। इवन आप भले ही
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर हो लेकिन आप इसकी वैल्यू
को नहीं देख सकते। ओनली सिस्टम ही देख
सकता है। अब सिस्टम प्रिलजेस आपको नहीं
मिल सकते। तो दिस सेम डेटाबेस इज़
प्रोटेक्ट प्रोटेक्टेड टू प्रिवेंट अन
ऑथोराइज एक्सेस टू सेंसिटिव यूजर
क्रेडेंशियल्स। लेकिन मैं आपको बता देता
हूं कि इसके अंदर भी एक हिरारिकल फॉर्म
में डेटा स्टोर किया जाता है। तो वो मैं
आपको समझाने की कोशिश करता हूं कि किस
फॉर्म में डाटा स्टोर किया जाता है। कभी
आपको मौका मिले तो। स्ट्रक्चर इसकी भी एक
स्ट्रक्चर होती है। स्ट्रक्चर ऑफ एचके
एलएम सेम रजिस्ट्री की। इस तरह की
स्ट्रक्चर होती है। सेम के अंदर सेम फिर
डोमेनस अकाउंट यूज़र्स यूज़र्स की
इंफॉर्मेशन नेम्स फिर ग्रुप्स एलियाज़
बिल्ट इन ये बिल्ट इन कुछ ग्रुप्स के नेम
पॉलिसीज सीक्रेट्स एलएसए ये ये और भी
ज्यादा ये एक छोटा सा स्क्रीनशॉट लिया हुआ
है। तो अभी कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट जो इसके अंदर
जो सब कीज़ है उनके बारे में डिस्कस करते
हैं कि क्या मतलब है? किस तरीके से डाटा
ऑर्गेनाइज रहता है इसके अंदर। एच लोकल
मशीन सेम सेम डोमेनस की बात करें। इसके
अंदर किस टाइप का डेटा स्टोर होता है? दिस
इज द कोर सेक्शन ऑफ द सेम रजिस्ट्री। इट
कंटेन सब कीज़ रिलेटेड टू द लोकल यूजर
अकाउंट ग्रुप्स एंड पॉलिसीज। आपका जो लोकल
यूजर अकाउंट्स है या उसके ग्रुप्स है उससे
रिलेटेड पॉलिसीज है वो इस डोमेनस के अंदर
के देखने को। देखो अकाउंट्स हैं, यूज़र्स
की इनेशन है, पॉलिसीज है, सीक्रेट सेलर्स
है। ये सारी किसके अंदर? आपके डोमेन के
अंदर है। तो ये सारी इंफॉर्मेशन इसके अंदर
स्टोर होती है। अब एच लोकल मशीन सेम सेम
डोमेनस के अंदर अब मैं अकाउंट की बात करता
हूं। यहां पर इस अकाउंट की बात करता हूं।
तो इसके अंदर कौन सा टाइप की इनेशन देखने
को मिलती है? दिस सब की कंटेंस यूजर
अकाउंट्स एंड रिलेटेड सिक्योरिटी। अब जो
यूजर अकाउंट है या उससे रिलेटेड जो भी
सिक्योरिटी है, सिक्योरिटी इनेशन है, वो
यहां पर आपकी कॉन्फ़िगर की जैसे यूज़र्स,
नेम्स, ग्रुप्स और एलियर्स। यूज़र्स के
अंदर आपको स्टोर्स लोकल यूजर अकाउंट डेटा
मैप्स यूजर्स नेम टू देयर एसआईडीज एंड
कंटेन लोकल ग्रुप इंफॉर्मेशन मैनेज यूजर
टू ग्रुप रिलेशनशिप एलियास क्या करता है
आपका यूजर टू ग्रुप रिलेशनशिप को मैनेज
करता है ग्रुप्स के अंदर आपके लोकल ग्रुप
इनेशन मिलेगी अगर यहां पर आपको ग्रुप्स
हां ये रहा ग्रुप्स के अंदर यहां पे कुछ
नहीं देखा और यूज़र्स के अंदर आपके लोकल
यूजर अकाउंट का डाटा इनेशन मिलेगी विद
एसआईडीज और नेम्स क्या करता है उस यूजरनेम
को उस एसआईडी के साथ क्या करता है मैप
करता है अभी हम बात करते हैं यूज़र्स के
अंदर क्या इनेशन देखो डोमेनस की बता दिया
अकाउंट का बता दिया यूज़र्स के अंदर दिस इज
द मोस्टेंट पार्ट ऑफ द सेम रजिस्ट्री ईच
यूजर इज आइडेंटिफाइड बाय ए आर आईडी
रिलेटिव आइडेंटिफायर होता है उसके द्वारा
ही हर एक यूजर को आइडेंटिफाई किया जाता है
ईच लोकल यूजर अकाउंट हैज़ ए यूनिक आर आईडी
अंडर यूज़र्स अभी ये क्या आर आईडीज है और
एसआईडीज यहां पर मैप की जाती है नेम्स के
अंदर नाउ नेक्स्ट बात करते हैं हम इसकी
किसकी नेम्स की अब नेम्स के अंदर अंदर
क्या देखने को मिलता है? यूज़र्स की मैंने
बता दिया अभी नेम्स के अंदर। दिस सब की
मैप्स यूजरनेम टू देयर आर आईडीज। आर आईडीज
दिस हेल्प विंडोज क्विकली ट्रांसलेट ए
यूजरनेम इंटू एन एसआईडी फॉर ऑथेंटिकेशन।
अब ऑथेंटिकेशन के लिए एसआईडीज का यूज़ किया
जाता है। सर्विस आइडेंटिफायर्स की मैं बात
कर रहा था। स्टार्टिंग में पढ़ा था। तो
इसने क्या किया? आर आईडी इन आरआईडी के साथ
मैप कर दिया। और लेकिन जब यूजर ऑथेंटिकेट
करता है तो इसी के थ्रू क्या कर पाता है?
वो कन्वर्ट कर पाता है किसके अंदर? एसआईडी
के अंदर। ओके? एचके लोकल मशीन सेम सेम
डोमेनस और बिल्ट इन की बात करते हैं हम तो
अभी ये रहा बिल्ट इन इसके अंदर क्या
इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को मिलती है ओके द बिल्ट
इन रजिस्ट्री की इनाइड द सेम डेटाबेस इज
रिस्पांसिबल फॉर मैनेजिंग बिल्ट इन
सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप्स इन Windows अभी
Windows जब भी इंस्टॉल की जाती है तो बाय
डिफॉल्ट Windows क्या करता है? ऑटोमेटिकली
कुछ सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप्स को क्रिएट कर देता
है। अब उन सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप को मैनेज करने
का काम क्या है? इसका काम इसके अंदर वो
सारे सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप्स मैनेज किए जाते
हैं या कोई अलग से सिक्योरिटी ग्रुप
डिफाइन किया गया है किसी भी कंपनी के
द्वारा एस पर देर पॉलिसी रिक्वायरमेंट तो
वो भी इसी के अंदर देखने को मिलेगा। दिस
सेक्शन कंटेंस बिल्ट इन विंडोज ग्रुप्स
जैसे एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स यूज़र्स या गेस्ट
इनकी आरआईडीज यहां पर नॉर्मली आपको देखने
को मिलेगी विद आर आईडीज। अभी नेक्स्ट हम
बात करते हैं एचके लोकल मशीन सेम सेम
डोमेनस और डोमस के अंदर एलियास का जो
पॉइंट था यह मैं इसको बताता हूं। यह नहीं
हमने बताया था। दी एचके लोकल मशीन सेम सेम
डोमस एलियास रजिस्ट्री की इज रिस्पांसिबल
फॉर मैनेजिंग लोकल ग्रुप्स एंड देयर
मेंबर्स ऑन ए विंडोज मशीन। अभी जो भी लोकल
ग्रुप्स हैं या उनके जो भी मेंबर्स हैं
आपको पता है कोई भी ग्रुप्स है तो उसके
मेंबर्स होंगे। उनको मैनेज करने का काम
किसका है? इसका एलियास का इट हेल्प्स
विंडज़ डिटरमाइन वि यूज़र्स बिलोंग टू वि
लोकल ग्रुप्स एंड ग्रांट देम एसोसिएट
परमिशंस। अब कौन सा मेंबर्स कौन से यूजर
ग्रुप से बिलोंग करता है और उसको किस टाइप
की परमिशंस एसोसिएट करनी है वो यहां पर ही
क्या की जाती है आपकी मैप की जाती है
एलियास के अंदर। तो यहां तक सबको क्लियर
है? कोई डाउट है किसी का या किसी को
बोरिंग तो नहीं लग रहा Windows
रजिस्ट्री कह सकते हो बट इट इज वेरी
इंटरेस्टिंग। जब इसके बारे में जानोगे जब
आप अटैक परफॉर्म करते हो ना विंडोज विलेज
एस्केलेशन तो अभी जो एडवांस में तो तब ये
सारी चीजें आपको ध्यान में रहेंग ना तो तो
आप आसानी से कर पाओगे
ओके अभी सीक्रेट्स की बात करते हैं यहां
पर क्या स्टोर रहता है आपके सीक्रेट्स के
अंदर दी एच लोकल मशीन सेम सेम सीक्रेट्स
रजिस्ट्री की स्टोर सेंसिटिव सिस्टम
सीक्रेट जैसे कि आपके कैच किए हुए
क्रेडेंशियल्स एलएसए सीक्रेट्स एंड सर्विस
अकाउंट जो यूज़ होते हैं उनके भी पासवर्ड्स
होते हैं वो भी पासवर्ड आपको इसके अंदर
देखने को मिलेंगे सीक्रेट्स के अंदर दीज़
सीक्रेट्स आर मैनेज्ड बाय द एलएसए लोकल
सिक्योरिटी अथॉरिटी है जो एलएसए आपको
दिखाया था रजिस्ट्री उसके द्वारा मैनेज
किए जाते हैं सीक्रेट एंड आर वेरी
क्रिटिकल फॉर विंडोज ऑथेंटिकेशन एंड
सिक्योरिटी मैकेनिज्म एक्सेसिंग एंड
मॉडिफाइंग दिस की रिक्वायर सिस्टम लेवल
प्रिलजेस। बताया ना मैंने यह सारे काम
करने के लिए आपको सिस्टम लेवल के प्रिलजेस
चाहिए जो किसी को असाइन नहीं किए जा सकते।
लेकिन आप हैक करके अगर सिस्टम लेवल के
प्रिलजेस ले लेते हैं किसी भी सिस्टम के
ऊपर देन बात अलग है। एंड इंप्रोपर चेंज
कैन लीड टू सिस्टम इनस्टेबिलिटी और
सिक्योरिटी वनेबिलिटीज।
नेक्स्ट एलएसए की बात करते हैं। इसके अंदर
भी एलएसए है। तो एचके लोकल मशीन सेम सेम
एलएसए रजिस्ट्री की इज द पार्ट ऑफ द
सिक्योरिटी अकाउंट मैनेजर डेटाबेस एंड इज
मैनेज्ड बाय द एलएसए ही स्टोर सिक्योरिटी
पॉलिसीज इंक्रिप्शन कीज़ एंड ऑथेंटिकेशन
सेटिंग। सोचो कि जो सेब डेटाबेस की जो
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स है कितनी इंपॉर्टेंट
फाइल्स है क्योंकि सारी मशीन का कंट्रोल
सारी मशीन की सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन जो एज ए
अटैकर्स पर्सेक्टिव एज ए पेन टेस्टर
पर्सेक्टिव कहां पर है इसके अंदर ही स्टोर
है तो आप इसको पढ़ सकते हो गो थ्रू कर
सकते हो हम नेक्स्ट स्लाइड पे चलते हैं
नेक्स्ट तो एचकेएलम सेम रजिस्ट्री की इज ए
क्रिटिकल कंपोनेंट ऑफ विंडोज ऑथेंटिकेशन
इट्स राइट अंडरस्टैंडिंग ऑफ स्ट्रक्चर
हेल्प विद विद सिक्योरिटी ऑडिटिंग
फॉरेंसिक इन्वेस्टिगेशंस एंड पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग डेफिनेटली इसको तो पढ़ना बहुतेंट
होता है क्योंकि काहे आप फॉरेंसिक
इन्वेस्टिगेशन करो चाहे आप पेन टेस्टिंग
करो चाहे सिक्योरिटी ऑडिटिंग करो ये इसकी
स्ट्रक्चर्स आपको पता होनी चाहिए सेम
रजिस्ट्री की एंड दैट इज द फाइल हैकर्स
वांट्स बिकॉज़ इट कंटेन्स ऑल यूजरनेम्स
पासवर्ड्स ग्रुप्स एंड सिक्योरिटी
डिस्क्रिप्टर्स अब इस फाइल पर सभी की नजर
रहती है हर एक अटैकर्स की चाहे ब्लैक वाइट
चाहे आप एथिकल किसी की भी बात करो हर एक
अटैकर्स की हर एक पेंटेस्टर्स की इसके ऊपर
तो नजर रहती ही रहती है। अगर आपको सिस्टम
के अंदर प्रिविलेज को एस्केलेट करना है या
चाहे आपको परमानेंट पर्सिस्टेंस क्रिएट
करना है क्योंकि अगर आपके पास
क्रेडेंशियल्स है मशीन के तो उससे अच्छी
बात तो हो ही नहीं सकती क्योंकि आप एक
वैलिड तरीके से ऑथेंटिकेट करोगे जहां पर
सिक्योरिटी टीम्स है उनका भी ध्यान कम
जाता है। ओके
नेक्स्ट अभी बात करते हैं सिक्योरिटी की।
अभी सिस्टम से रिलेटेड हमने बात कर ली एच
की लोकल मशीन। अभी सिक्योरिटी से रिलेटेड
बात करते हैं। यहां तक किसी का और डाउट है
मुझसे पूछ सकते हैं। यहां तक सबको समझ में
आ गया। प्रशांत
शर्मा मुझे पहली बात तो आपका डाउट समझ में
नहीं आ रहा। दूसरी बात
व्हाई यू आर कमिंग इन द क्लास? क्योंकि आप
सेशन के बीच में आपके सवाल अलग हैं। आप
पूछ कुछ रहे हो तो आप वेट नहीं कर सकते।
अगर आप वेट नहीं कर सकते तो यू कैन लीव द
क्लास। अदरवाइज वेट फॉर द एंड और मुझे सही
से सवाल पूछिए।
ओके। तो अब सिक्योरिटी से रिलेटेड बात
करते हैं। द एचके लोकल मशीन सिक्योरिटी
रजिस्ट्री हैव इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर
स्टोरिंग सिक्योरिटी रिलेटेड सेटिंग्स बाय
Windows। अब Windows की जो सिक्योरिटी से
रिलेटेड जो भी सेटिंग्स है, जो भी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस होती है, वह इस रजिस्ट्री की
के अंदर कॉन्फ़िगर की जाती हैं। इवन
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर अकाउंट कैन नॉट एक्सेस दिस
की। अभी एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर अकाउंट भी इसको
एक्सेस नहीं कर जैसे सैम को डेटाबेस को
एक्सेस नहीं कर सकता। इसको भी एक्सेस नहीं
कर सकता। ओनली सिस्टम प्रिलजेस कैन रीड और
मॉडिफाई इट्स डेटा। मतलब ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
ही इसको रीड और मॉडिफाई कर सकता है। दिस
रिस्ट्रिक्शन इज़ टू प्रिवेंट अटैकर्स
फ्रॉम स्टीलिंग क्रेडेंशियल्स और
मॉडिफाइंग सिक्योरिटी सेटिंग। अभी अभी
इतना हार्ड रिस्ट्रिक्शन लगा दिया जिससे
क्या है? अटैकर्स के लिए तो बहुत बड़ा
चैलेंज होता है कि क्रेडेंशियल को क्या
करना? स्टील करना और मॉडिफाई करना। ओके?
नाउ
नेक्स्ट अभी बात करते हैं एचके लोकल मशीन
सॉफ्टवेयर की सिक्योरिटी से रिलेटेड बात
की अब सॉफ्टवेयर से रिलेटेड बात करते हैं
देखो अब जितने भी सॉफ्टवेयर्स हैं जितने
भी सॉफ्टवेयर इंस्टॉल्स हैं उनकी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन इसके अंदर की जाती है इंस्टॉल
सिस्टम वाइड सॉफ्टवेयर कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस
इंस्टॉल प्रोग्राम
ड्राइवर्स एंड सिक्योरिटी सेटिंग्स दैट
अफेक्ट ऑल यूज़र्स ऑन द कंप्यूटर जैसा मैं
जैसा कि मैंने आपको बताया जितने भी आपके
प्रोग्राम इंस्टॉल किए हैं चाहे ड्राइवर्स
हैं उससे सिक्योरिटी कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस हैं वह
सारी की सारी इसके अंदर क्फ़िगर की जाती है
और जो सभी यूज़र्स को इफेक्ट करती है। दी
एच लोकल मशीन सॉफ्टवेयर रजिस्ट्री हैव
अप्लाई सिस्टम वाइज सेटिंग्स मीनिंग चेंजज़
हियर अफेक्ट ऑल यूज़र्स ऑन द मशीन इट इज
डिफरेंट फ्रॉम एच की करंट यूजर सॉफ्टवेयर।
वहां पर भी आपको देखने को मिलेगा एच की
करंट यूज़र्स है। उसके अंदर भी एक
सॉफ्टवेयर रजिस्ट्री देखने को मिलेगी।
लेकिन उससे में और इसमें दोनों में
डिफरेंस है क्योंकि यहां पर पूरे सिस्टम्स
को अफेक्ट करेगा और यहां पर ओनली एचके
करंट यूज़र्स में ओनली उस पर्टिकुलर यूजर
को ही अफेक्ट करेगी ये कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल।
दैट इज द
डिफरेंस। सबको समझ में आ रहा है या थोड़ा
सा फास्ट हो रहा है? बताइए।
फास्ट हो रहा है समझ नहीं आ
रहा क्या समझ में नहीं आ
रहा मतलब आपको समझ समझ में नहीं आ रहा।
हां बिल्कुल खुद से पढ़ोगे तो वही चीज मैं
आपको समझा रहा हूं जो इसमें लिखा है
एग्जजेक्टली ट्रुथ है राइट है और खुद के
नोट्स बनाओगे तो अच्छा रहेगा और डोंट वरी
दिस इज द लास्ट फंडामेंटल सेशन देन उसके
बाद जो नेक्स्ट सेशन होगा आपका मे बी
Windows की जो कमांड प्र्ट है सीएलआई है
उसके ऊपर कमांड्स कैसे रन करते हैं तो
उनकी हम प्रैक्टिस करेंगे Windows CLI की
कमांड प्र्ट के ऊपर कौन-कौन सी कमांड्स
कैसे रन करते हैं। जैसे Linux की कमांड रन
करते हैं। ऐसे Windows के ऊपर भी कमांड्स
होती है। उन कमांड्स के बारे में इनेशन
लेंगे। देन उसके बाद हम पेन टेस्टिंग
स्टार्ट करेंगे। बट आप लोग आते नहीं तो ये
सारी चीजें बहुत समय लेने वाली हैं। अभी
ओके। अभी हम बात करते हैं एच की लोकल मशीन
हार्डवेयर। एच लोकल मशीन हार्डवेयर की बात
करते दी एचके लोकल मशीन हार्डवेयर
रजिस्ट्री हाईव इज ए वोलेटाइल एक टेंपरेरी
रजिस्ट्री की है जो आपकी रियल टाइम
इंफॉर्मेशन को स्टोर करती है किससे
रिलेटेड हार्डवेयर डिवाइसेस से रिलेटेड
बाकी दूसरी रजिस्टरों की तरह नहीं है कि
जो डिस्क पे इंफॉर्मेशन को स्टोर करती है
नहीं इट इज़ अ डायनेमिकली जनरेटेड बाय द
Windows कर्नल ड्यूरिंग सिस्टम बूट जैसे
Windows कर्नल आपका अह बूट करता है सिस्टम
बूट करता है तो Windows कर्नल के अलावा
डायनेमिकली इस रजिस्ट्री अह को जनरेट किया
मतलब यह रजिस्ट्री अवेलेबल रहती है लेकिन
इसके अंदर जो रियल टाइम इनेशन है वह कर्नल
के द्वारा क्या की जाती है जनरेट की जाती
है और जैसे आपका सिस्टम पावर ऑफ होगा तो
इसकी जो इंफॉर्मेशन है गायब हो जाती है द
एचके लोकल मशीन हार्डवेयर रजिस्ट्री हैव
इज प्राइमरली यूज्ड बाय Windows टू स्टोर
लाइव इंफॉर्मेशनेशन अबाउट सिस्टम
हार्डवेयर जैसे कि सीपीयू मेमोरी बस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस बायoस यूएफआई डिटेल्स प्लग
एंड प्लग डिवाइसेस या स्टोरेज कंट्रोल या
ड्राइवर्स की बात करें। सभी केस में क्या
है कि यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन इसके अंदर स्टोर
रहती है हार्डवेयर के अंदर। ओके?
तो जब भी आप क्या करते हो कोई कमांड रन
करते हो और आपको देखने को मिलता कितना
सीपीू कंजमशन हो रहा है। आप देखते हो यहां
पर टास्क मैनेजर के अंदर तो जो लाइव रियल
टाइम जो इंफॉर्मेशन आपको कहां से देखने को
मिल रही है? इस रजिस्ट्री की से देखने को
मिल रही है।
ओके तो भैया अश्विन अगर आपके पास नॉलेज
है, आपके पास अगर कैपेबिलिटी है और आपके
पास सारी चीजें हैं तो डेफिनेटली यू गेट द
जॉब। अदरवाइज एक छोटे से टॉपिक से तो जॉब
नहीं मिलती। जॉब के लिए तो बहुत कुछ
प्रिपरेशन करना पड़ता है भैया। ऐसे नहीं
होता। तो एचके लोकल मशीन बीसीडी के बारे
में बात करते हैं। इसके अंदर क्या
इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती है? द एचके लोकल मशीन जो
बीसीडी रजिस्ट्री हाई स्टोर बूट
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन डेटा। क्या स्टोर करती हैं?
बूट कॉन्फ़िगरेशन डेटा। बीसीडी व्हिच
डिफाइन हाउ Windows स्टार्टअप जो यह
डिफाइन करता मतलब बूट की जो भी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स होती हैं, वह बीसीडी
जो रजिस्ट्री आए हुए यहां पर स्टोर कर
करके रख दी जाती है। तो, यहां से आपकी
Windows को पता चलता है बीसीडी कि को बूट
कैसे करना है। इट कंटेंस क्रिटिकल बूट
सेटिंग लाइक बूट लोडर एंट्रीज, बूट
पैरामीटर्स, ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम सेक्शन,
रिकवरी ऑप्शन एंड हाइपरवाइजर सेटिंग्स। इट
इज यूज्ड बाय द Windows बूट मैनेजर टू
डिटरमाइन हाउ द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम बूट्स
आपका ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कैसे बूट करेगा इसकी
जो कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस है वो इस रजिस्ट्री के
अंदर रख दी जाती है कॉन्फ़िगर करके इस
रजिस्ट्री के अंदर आपको देखने को मिलेगी
बूट से रिलेटेड जो भी कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस हैं।
तो शायद एचके लोकल मशीन का आपके बारे में
पता चल गया होगा कि हार्डवेयर रजिस्ट्री
का क्या मतलब है? सेम रजिस्ट्री,
सिक्योरिटी रजिस्ट्री, सॉफ्टवेयर
रजिस्ट्री या सिस्टम रजिस्ट्री ऐसा बीसीडी
रजिस्ट्री है। ये जो छह की छह रजिस्ट्री
है एचके लोकल मशीन के अंदर किसके अंदर
इंफॉर्मेशन सिस्टम के अंदर आपकी सिस्टम से
रिलेटेड जितनी भी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन सेटिंग्स
होती है, वो देखने को मिलती है। सॉफ्टवेयर
में सॉफ्टवेयर से रिलेटेड है। सिक्योरिटी
में जितनी भी सिक्योरिटी सेटिंग्स होती
हैं, वह इसके अंदर सैम के अंदर आपकी
ऑथेंटिकेशन से रिलेटेड जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन
है या जो भी सिक्योरिटीज है, उसकी चाहे
कीज़ हो, कुछ भी हो, आपको SAM के अंदर
हार्डवेयर में रियल टाइम इंफॉर्मेशन आपको
देखने को मिलती है। और बीसीडी के अंदर
आपकी जो Windows बूट कैसे करेगा, उसकी जो
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस है, वह यहां पर इस रजिस्टर
के अंदर डिफाइन की जाती है।
ओके तो नेक्स्ट चले
चलिए नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट स्लाइड पर यहां तक
सबको क्लियर
है। सभी लोग आंसर कीजिए यार। आंसर करने
में क्या प्रॉब्लम है?
ओके। तो अभी हम बात करते हैं एच की
क्लासेस रूट की। एच की क्लासेस रूट की हम
बात करते हैं। इस रजिस्ट्री की के अंदर
क्या मिलता है? एच की क्लासेस रूट इज द
पार्ट ऑफ द रजिस्ट्री दैट कंट्रोल्स हाउ
फाइल्स, फोल्डर्स, लिंक्स एंड राइट क्लिक
मेन्यूज़ वर्क इन विंडोज़। जब भी आप क्या
करते हो? किसी भी फाइल्स या फोल्डर को या
किसी भी लिंक को क्लिक करते हो या राइट
क्लिक करते हो और जब उसके बाद जो भी
ऑप्शंस आपको देखने को मिलते हैं और जैसे
उस ऑप्शंस पे आप क्लिक करते हो उसके
अगेंस्ट जो भी फाइल ओपन होती है वो सारी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस इसके अंदर की जाती है
क्लासेस रूट के अंदर। व्हेन यू फॉर
एग्जांपल व्हेन यू डबल क्लिक ए फाइल जब
फॉर एग्जांपल आप किसी भी एक फाइल के ऊपर
डबल क्लिक करते हैं तो विंडो चेक करती है
इसके अंदर। विंडो चेक एच की सीआर एच की
क्लास रूट के अंदर टू फिगर आउट व्हाट
प्रोग्राम्स टू ओपन इट विद कि मुझे इस
फाइल को किस प्रोग्राम से ओपन करना है।
व्हेन यू राइट क्लिक ए फाइल और फोल्डर या
किसी भी राइट फोल्डर पे आप राइट क्लिक
करते हो तो एच एच की क्लासेस रूट हेल्प
डिसाइड व्हाट स्वप इन दैट मेनू। अब जैसे
आप राइट क्लिक करते हो तो वहां पर बहुत
सारे ऑप्शंस आपको देखने को मिलते हैं। वो
ऑप्शन किसकी वजह से आते हैं? वह इसकी वजह
से आते हैं। इस रजिस्ट्री की की वजह से
आते हैं। वह सारे ऑप्शन राइट क्लिक के साथ
जैसे कि फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने अभी एग्जांपल
दिखा ही देता हूं आपको कि हम चलते हैं। ये
रहा ये रहा एक फोल्डर मेरा ये रहा। राइट
क्लिक किया। यह रहा। इतने सारे जो ऑप्शंस
आए हैं ओपन शेयर यह किसकी वजह से आ रहे
हैं? रजिस्ट्री की की वजह से ऑप्शंस आ रहे
हैं। सारे के सारे ऑप्शंस किसकी वजह से आ
रहे हैं आपके? रजिस्ट्री की की वजह से आ
रहे हैं। फॉर एग्जांपल यह रहा राइट क्लिक
यह रहा। तो ये सारे ऑप्शन किसकी वजह से आ
रहे हैं आपके? रजिस्ट्री की। कौन सी? इसकी
वजह से। ये सारी चीजें डिफाइंड है इसके
अंदर। नेक्स्ट फॉर एग्जांपल आपके पास एक
टेक्स्ट फाइल है आपकी विंडो मशीन के अंदर।
और जैसे आप डबल क्लिक करते हो तो डबल
क्लिक करने पर सबसे पहले आपकी मशीन क्या
करती है? एच की क्लास रूट के अंदर जाती है
और जैसे एच की क्लास रूट के अंदर जाती है
तो वो चेक करती है आपकी इस रजिस्ट्री की
के अंदरxt क्योंकि उसका एक्सटेंशन क्या है
आपका txt तो उस एक्सटेंशन पे जाएगी उस
रजिस्ट्री की केxt के ऊपर देखेंगे ओके
यहां पर डिफॉल्ट के अंदर क्या है टेक्स्ट
फाइल लिगेसी अब ये टेक्स्ट फाइल लिगेसी को
चेक करती है फर्दर आगे जाती है तो उसी के
अंदर देखो किसके अंदर एचके लोकल रूट
टेक्स्ट फाइल लिगेसी के अंदर उसके अंदर
अंदर क्या है? सेल। सेल के अंदर प्रिंटो
के अंदर कमांड है। तो यहां पर वो देखो
सिस्टम रूट सिस्टम 32 नोटपड. जब मैं डबल
क्लिक करता हूं या मैं राइट डबल क्लिक
किया जैसे टेक्स्ट फाइल पे तो मेरी जो
पहले बाय डिफॉल्ट जो फाइल ओपन होती है
किसके साथ ओपन होती है? नोटपड के साथ।
किसके साथ ओपन होती है? डबल क्लिक के साथ?
नोटपड के साथ। अभी यह आपकी मशीन को पता
कैसे चला कि मुझे यह जो टेक्स्ट फाइल है,
नोटपड एप्लीकेशन के साथ ओपन करनी है।
बिकॉज़ ऑफ दिस। Windows ने चेक किया और
वहां पर उसको मिली एक कमांड
नोटपड.exec pt परसेंटेज 1 2 3 4 व्हाटएवर
उसके बाद आपकी फाइल को ओपन कर दिया। समझ
में आया कि जब आपने डबल क्लिक किया या
राइट क्लिक किया तो वह सारे ऑप्शंस कहां
से आते हैं और आपकी विंडो को पता कैसे
चलता है? वह पता चलता है आपके इसकी वजह
से। यह रहा h की क्लास रूट की वजह से।
क्लियर?
ओके यहां तक सबको समझ में आया
अभी कि जो अभी मैंने आपको बताया कि एच के
क्लास रूट के की कितनीेंस है क्योंकि आपको
पता ही नहीं कि आप जब Windows में जो भी
कुछ काम कर रहे हो वो किसकी देन है आपकी?
रजिस्ट्री की। क्योंकि वो सारी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस आपके रजिस्ट्री के अंदर
कॉन्फ़िगर की गई हुई
है। इंटरेस्टेड? सबको मजा
आया? इंटरेस्ट बना क्लास में और
भी? नेक्स्ट
अभी बात करते हैं हम एच की क्लास यूजर्स
की जिसको हम एच के सीयू बोलेंगे एच की
ओके एच की क्लास यूजर की अभी एच के क्लास
यूजर का क्या पर्पज है यहां पे देखें एच
की
ओके ओके ओके क्लास यूजर करंट यूजर ओके एच
के करंट यूजर सॉरी आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट दिस
वन एच के करंट यूज़र्स की हम बात करते हैं
एच उसकी करंट यूजर स्टोर सेटिंग्स एंड
प्रेफरेंसेस दैट आर स्पेसिफिक टू द करंटली
लॉक्ड इन यूजर ओनली। जब भी आप क्या करते
हो अपनी विंडो मशीन के अंदर लॉगिन करते हो
तो उससे रिलेटेड भी बहुत सारी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
सेटिंग्स होती हैं। उससे रिलेटेड
पर्टिकुलर्स आपके सॉफ्टवेयर्स होते हैं।
वही यूज़र्स जैसे आप लॉग इन करते हो तो
उसके बहुत सारी उसका डेस्कटॉप होगा। उसका
एक डेस्कटॉप एनवायरमेंट होगा और उसके एक
थीम्स होगी। उसके कीबोर्ड माउस की
लैंग्वेज प्रेफरेंसेस होंगे या उसकी
एप्लीकेशनेशंस की सेटिंग्स होगी उस
पर्टिकुलर यूजर के हिसाब से। तो वो सारी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस इसके अंदर सेट मिलती हैं। तो
इट होल्ड द पर्सनल इंफॉर्मेशनेशन लाइक
डेस्कटॉप वॉलपेपर। जैसे मैं इस पर्टिकुलर
फॉर एग्जांपल सचिन सचिन नाम के मैं अगर
यूजरनेम से लॉगिन करूंगा तो मेरा डेस्कटॉप
वॉलपेपर ये देखने को मिलेगा। उसकी थीम कौन
सी होगी? उसका कीबोर्ड माउस की सेटिंग
क्या होंगी? लैंग्वेज प्रेफरेंसेस इंग्लिश
होगा, हिंदी होगा उसके कीबोर्ड का। फाइल
एक्सप्लोर प्रेफरेंसेस क्या होंगी?
एप्लीकेशनेशंस की सेटिंग्स क्या होंगी या
कौन-कौन सी एप्लीकेशनेशंस होंगी? तो ये
सारी की सारी इंफॉर्मेशन क्या है आपकी?
इसके अंदर देखने को मिलती है। एच की करंट
यूज़र्स के अंदर थोड़े से एक्सप्लेन कर
देता हूं। देखिए एच के करंट यूजर आपको
कंसोल देखने को मिल रहा। तो यहां पर आपको
मिलता है कमांड प्रॉप्ट सेटिंग्स कि उसका
कलर, विंडोज साइज और फोंट इसके अंदर सेट
मिलता है उस पर्टिकुलर यूजर के अगेंस्ट।
कंट्रोल पैनल के अंदर उसका डेस्कटॉप,
माउस, साउंड या कीबोर्ड से सेटिंग्स आपको
देखने को मिलती है। कीबोर्ड लेआउट, इनपुट
मेथड और लेग्स प्रेफरेंसेस यहां पर
नेटवर्क ड्राइव मैपिंग यहां पर मिलेंगी।
प्रिंटर्स से सेटिंग प्रिंटर से रिलेटेड
जो सेटिंग्स आपको प्रिंटर्स के अंदर देखने
को मिलेंगी। सॉफ्टवेयर सेटिंग्स हैं कि
सॉफ्टवेयर फॉर इंस्टॉल प्रोग्राम्स पर
यूज़र्स के हिसाब से जो सॉफ्टवेयर
इंस्टॉल्ड है उसकी जो सेटिंग्स है उनकी जो
कॉन्फ़िगरेशनंस है वो इसके अंदर सेट मिलती
है। वोलेटाइल एनवायरमेंट जो भी आपके
टेंपरेरी सेशंस इनेशन होती है जैसे
यूजरनेम है टेंपरेरी पाथ से हैं वो सारे
वोलेटाइल एनवायरमेंट के अंदर देखने को
मिलेंगे। जैसे एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल्स होते
हैं। जैसे आपको पता होगा Linux के अंदर
पाथ वेरिएबल होता है। उसी प्रकार से इसके
अंदर भी एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल्स होते हैं
बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट किसी भी यूज़र्स के लिए। तो वो
सारी की सारी सेटिंग्स इस रजिस्ट्री के
अंदर देखने को मिले। तो जो पर्टिकुलर
रजिस्ट्री है एच के करंट यूजर्स यह
पर्टिकुलर जो यूज़र्स लॉग इन किया हुआ है
उसकी जो भी पर्टिकुलर यूज़र्स से रिलेटेड
जो भी कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस है वह सारी इसके अंदर
सेट मिलती है। चाहे उसका डेस्कटॉप से लेके
माउस कीबोर्ड या आपने चाहे एक्सटर्नल
हेडफोन यूज़ किया, ब्लूटूथ यूज़ किया,
व्हाटएवर द सेटिंग्स वो सारी की सारी यहां
पर देखने को मिलती हैं। ओके
क्लियर यह क्लियर है?
ओके। नेक्स्ट अब बात करते हैं हम एच की
यूज़र्स की। अभी एच की यूज़र्स के अंदर आपको
देखने को मिल रहा है डिफ़ॉल्ट। फिर ये कुछ
एस आईडीज देखने को मिल रही है। डिफ़ॉल्ट के
अंदर आपका जो डिफ़ॉल्ट यूज़र्स होता है आपका
किसका? Windows का। इसका मतलब है डिफ़ॉल्ट।
बाकी ये आपके यूज़र्स हो सकते हैं। आपके
सिस्टम यूज़र्स भी हो सकते हैं या आपके
एक्सटर्नल यूज़र्स भी हो सकते हैं। तो एच
की यूज़र्स इज द पार्ट ऑफ रजिस्ट्री दैट
कंटेन ऑल यूजर प्रोफाइल्स लोडेड ऑन द
सिस्टम नॉट जस्ट द वन करंटली लॉग इन। अब
इसके अंदर जो इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती है इसके
अंदर वो इंफॉर्मेशन मिलेगी। जितने भी
यूज़र्स ने लॉग इन किया है इस मशीन के अंदर
जितने भी यूज़र्स हैं जितने भी यूज़र्स
इसमें क्रिएट किए हुए हैं आपने और जितने
भी यूज़र्स के द्वारा आप इसमें लॉग इन करते
हैं चाहे आपके 1000 यूज़र्स क्यों ना हो वो
सब के सब यहां पर उसकी प्रोफाइल
इंफॉर्मेशन यहां पर मिलेगी। यूज़र्स की
प्रोफाइल जो इनेशन है यहां पर मिलेगी। इफ
मोर देन वन यूज़र्स लॉक्ड इन लॉक्ड ऑन देन
इट विल स्टोर ऑल दैट इनेशन इन दिस एचकेय।
इट कंटेन सब की कॉस्पोंडिंग टू ईच यूजर
प्रोफाइल। बेसिकली वी कैन से दैट मिरर ऑफ
एचकेयू जो एचके करंट यूज़र्स होता है। बट
हर एक यूज़र्स के रिलेटेड उसकी जो खुद की
जो कॉन्फ़िगरेशन सेटिंग्स है वो इसके अंदर
देखने को मिलती है। लेकिन उसका मिरर यहां
पर भी क्रिएट मिलेगा कि क्योंकि 1 2 3 4 5
जैसे यहां पर क्या है कि पांच यूज़र्स नहीं
लेकिन मेरी मशीन में दो यूज़र्स हैं। तो उन
दो पर्टिकुलर यूज़र्स की जो यहां पर
एसआईडीज है उसके अगेंस्ट बिल्कुल एच के जो
करंट यूज़र्स की जो सेटिंग्स है यहां पर
मैच करेंगी। तो बेसिकली यू कैन से दैट यह
ओनली किसी स्पेसिफिक यूजर से रिलेटेड नहीं
है। जितने भी यूज़र्स मशीन के अंदर लॉगिन
किए हुए हैं सभी यूज़र्स की प्रोफाइल्स
यहां पर देखने को प्रोफाइल के अंदर वो
सारी सेटिंग्स मिलेंग जो लॉगिन करते वक्त
जो एच के करंट यूज़र्स के अंदर देखने को
मिलेगी। इट इज अ मिरर ऑफ एच के करंट
यूज़र्स। तो सबको शायद यह भी क्लियर हो गया
होगा।
नेक्स्ट अभी हम बात करते हैं कि व्हाट
टाइप ऑफ डाटा इज़ स्टोर इन द रजिस्ट्री। अब
जो रजिस्ट्री है, रजिस्ट्री के अंदर किस
टाइप की इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को मिलती
है। जैसे कि आपने देखा होगा कि यह रहा यह
रजिस्ट्री की है। मैं जब किसी भी की पर
क्लिक करूं देखो डबल क्लिक किया देखो
सॉफ्टवेयर है। यह
रहा यह रहा। यहां पे इनेशन देखो नेम है,
डेटा है और टाइप है। देखिए मीडिया के अंदर
यह रहा। प्रेजेंटेशन के अंदर यह है।
Google यहां क्लिक किया यह रहा। यहां पर
क्लिक किया यह रहा। एक्सटेंशन नेविगेशन
यह रहा यह रहा यह रहा। तो किस टाइप यह दो
तो आपके जो इसके अंदर डाटा टाइप्स हैं वह
कौन सा है आपका? बेसिकली यही है। यह
रहा रेग नन कोई भी वैल्यू टाइप की वैल्यू
नहीं है। नन है। रैग एसzेड आपने देखा
फिक्स्ड लेंथ यूनिकोड स्ट्रिंग रैग
एक्सपेंड एसzेड वेरिएबल लेंथ यूनिकोड
स्ट्रिंग दैट कैन बी एंबेडेड एनवायरमेंट
वेरिएबल्स। लेकिन सबसे ज्यादा 90% ऑफ दी
जो वैल्यू आपको सेट मिलेगी यही मिलेगी रेक
बाइनरी और रेक डी वर्ड रेक बाइनरी
आर्बिट्रेरी लेंथ बाइनरी डाटा और 32 बिट
नंबर 90% आपको यह देखने को मिलेगा 10%
इनमें से कुछ भी देखने को मिलेगा जैसे
यूनिकोड सिंबॉलिक लिंक तो ये वैल्यू सेट
मिलेगी टाइप के अंदर हार्डवेयर रिसोर्सेज
डिस्क्रिप्शन से रिलेटेड ये वैल्यू सेट
मिलेगी रैग क्यूवर्ड 64 बिट नंबर के लिए
ये वैल्यू सेट मिलेगी या फिर नन के लिए
रैग नन ये वैल्यू वैल्यू आपको सेट मिलेगी।
तो इस टाइप्स का आपको डाटा देखने को मिलता
है आपके रजिस्ट्री कीज़ के अंदर। नेक्स्ट
डेटा इन ए वैल्यू नेम शुड नेवर बी मोर देन
वन से 2 KB इन साइज। अभी जो भी डेटा स्टोर
किया जाता है इन रजिस्ट्री कीज़ के अंदर जो
वैल्यू है उसका साइज एक या 2 KB से ऊपर
नहीं होता। दे देयर शुड नेवर एग्ज़िस्ट
एग्जीक्यूटेबल कोड इन द रजिस्ट्री की। अब
जो रजिस्ट्री कीज़ होती है उसके अंदर कभी
भी कोई भी एग्जीक्यूटेबल कोड स्टोर नहीं
होता। मॉडर्न विंडो की बात करें तो ओवर 3
मिलियन कीज़ एंड वैल्यू्यूज इन द
रजिस्ट्री। अब मॉडर्न विंडोज़ के केस में
जो टोटल अगर फाइंड आउट करोगे तो इसकी जो
टोटल कीज़ और वैल्यू्यूज पे देखने को
मिलेंगे 3 मिलियन से भी ज्यादा हैं। मोर
देन 3 मिलियंस। ये जस्ट एक रफ आईडिया है।
Google की है तो इतनी ये जो Microsoft की
साइट पे मिल जाएंगे आपको। ओवर द मोर देन 3
मिलियन सब की वैल्यू्यूज पेयर मिल जाए। तो
कैसे याद कर सकते हो? आप इसको याद कर ही
नहीं सकते। ओके? द रजिस्ट्री की इज ए
क्रिटिकल कंपोनेंट टू हैकर रनिंग देयर
मिलिशियस कोड ईच टाइम यू बूट। अभी
रजिस्ट्री की होती है किसी भी अटैकर्स के
लिए एक क्रिटिकल कंपोनेंट होता है। खास
करके जब उसे कोई मिलेशियस कोड रन करना
होता है जब वह सिस्टम बूट करे। टू एडिट द
रजिस्ट्री की बी श्योर यू आर लॉक्ड ऑन विद
एडमिन राइट्स टू लोकल मशीन। अगर आपको इस
रजिस्ट्री की को एडिट भी करना है तो आपके
पास एडमिन राइट होने चाहिए लोकल मशीन के
ऊपर। अदरवाइज यू कैन नॉट एडिट द रजिस्ट्री
कीज़। और सभी रजिस्ट्री कीज़ को तो आप भी
एडिट नहीं कर सकते। जो सिस्टम लेवल की
प्रिलिजेस चाहिए जिन रजिस्ट्री कीज़ को
उनको तो आप एडिट ही नहीं कर सकते। आप
उन्हीं रजिस्ट्री की को एडिट कर सकते हो
जिनके ऊपर आपके प्रिलजेस हैं। आप
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर हो तो एडमिन वाली
रजिस्ट्री एडिट कर सकते हो। अगर आप एक
नॉर्मल यूज़र हैं तो आप एक नॉर्मल यूज़र्स
वाली रजिस्ट्री को एडिट कर सकते हो। सारी
की सारी रजिस्ट्री को आप खुद से एडिट नहीं
कर सकते। और कभी करने की कोशिश भी मत
करना। डायरेक्टली रे एडिट जो मैंने
रजिस्ट्री एडिटर दिखाया इसके अंदर वैल्यू
को डायरेक्टली चेंज करने की कोशिश मत करना
क्योंकि अगर आपने सही से इसको सेट नहीं
किया और प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट होगी तो आपको पता
भी नहीं चलेगा कि कहां पर प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट
होगी।
ओके यहां तक सबको क्लियर है। आई थिंक
नेक्स्ट स्लाइड पर चलते
हैं। नहीं नहीं Windows हार्निंग वीडियो
विल नॉट कम ऑन द Windows फंडामेंटल्स
बिकॉज़ इट इज़ द पार्ट ऑफ द शॉक
एनालिस्ट। या आप बात कर सकते हो डिफेंसिव
साइड या आपके जो Windows हार्डनिंग करनी
पड़ती है आपके सिस्टम एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर को और
यू आर नॉट ए सिस्टम एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर।
ओके। नेक्स्ट हम बात करते हैं हु यूज द
Windows रजिस्ट्री की। अब Windows
रजिस्ट्री कीज़ को कौन-कौन यूज़ करता है?
सारी की सारी थर्ड पार्टी एप्लीकेशन
Windows रजिस्ट्री को यूज़ करती है। आपकी
यूजर इंटरफ़ेस यूज़ करती हैं। सेम डेटाबेस
यूज़ करता है। सारी की सारी सर्विज आपकी
Windows रजिस्ट्री को यूज़ करती है। सारे
डिवाइस ड्राइवर्स हैं, आपका चाहे कर्नल्स
हैं। सभी के सभी आपके क्या करते हैं?
Windows रजिस्ट्री को यूज़ करते हैं। हु डज़
नॉट यूज़ द Windows रजिस्ट्री? अभी Windows
रजिस्ट्री को कौन यूज़ नहीं करता? डॉट नेट
डॉट नेट फ्रेमवर्क एप्लीकेशनेशंस Windows
रजिस्ट्री को यूज नहीं करती। वो अपनी जो
डॉट नेट फ्रेमवर्क से बनी हुई जो
एप्लीकेशनेशंस है वो अपनी फाइल्स को
कॉन्फ़िगर करने के लिए वो एक्सML का यूज़
करती हैं। वो अपनी एप्लीकेशनेशंस को
कॉन्फ़िगर करने के लिए एक्सML फाइल का यूज
करती हैं। एंड दे डू नॉट यूज़ द रजिस्ट्री।
पोर्टेबल एप्लीकेशनेशंस यूजली कीप देयर
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस डेटा विद इन देयर फाइल्स इन
देयर डिक्शनरी एंड फोल्डर्स वेद एप्लीकेशन
एग्जीक्यूटेबल रिसाइज़। कई बार कुछ ऐसी
पोर्टेबल्स एप्लीकेशनेशंस होती हैं जो
Windows रजिस्ट्री का यूज़ नहीं करती जो
अपनी कॉन्फ़िगरेशनंस फाइल्स को क्या करती
है? जब उस एप्लीकेशन को आप डाउनलोड करते
हो, उसकी जिप फाइल को डाउनलोड करते हो,
जहां पर उसकी एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल होती है,
वहीं पर उसकी कॉन्फ़िगरेशनंस फाइल्स भी
देखने को आपको मिल जाएंगी। तो वह भी आपकी
क्या है? Windows रजिस्ट्री को यूज़ नहीं
करती। लेकिन 90% जो आपकी थर्ड पार्टी
एप्लीकेशनेशंस है, चाहे आपके यूजर इंटरफ़ेस
है, चाहे आपका सेम डेटाबेस है, चाहे आपके
सर्विज है, चाहे आपके डिवाइस ड्राइवर्स
हैं, आपके कर्नल है, सभी क्या करते हैं?
आपके Windows रजिस्ट्री को यूज करते हैं।
नेक्स्ट बात करते हैं व्हाट आर द अप्रूव्ड
टूल्स Microsoft अलाउ अस
टू यूज टू मॉडिफाई आवर रजिस्ट्री? कि अगर
आपको तो रजिस्ट्री को मॉडिफाई भी करना है।
तो Microsoft ने कोई ऐसा टूल अलाउ किया
है। किसी को पता है कि अगर मुझे इन
रजिस्ट्री को मॉडिफाई करना है तो आपको कोई
आईडिया है कि किस टूल से हम रजिस्ट्री को
मॉडिफाई कर सकते हैं। डस हैव एनीवन एनी
आईडिया। किसी का कोई भी आईडिया है।
नहीं विनोद ठाकुर अगर आप एक नॉर्मल यूज़र्स
हो तो आप बताइए आप अपनी रजिस्ट्री को कैसे
मॉडिफाई करते हो और आप करते हो आप करते
हो नहीं प्रोसेस एक्सप्लोरर रजिस्ट्री को
मॉडिफाई नहीं
करता तो एडमिन बन के भी कहां पर कॉन्फ़िगर
करते हो।
बताइए आप एक एडमिन हो तो आपको अगर अपनी
रजिस्ट्री कॉन्फ़िगर रजिस्ट्री के अंदर
वैल्यूज़ को चेंज करना है तो आप कैसे
कॉन्फ़िगर
करोगे? बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट जब आप Windows को
इंस्टॉल करते हो आप एडमिन होते
हो J एप्लीकेशन यूज़ करके।
आप यूज करते हो।
देखिए यह टूल देखा आपने कंट्रोल
पैनल किसी ने देखा यह कंट्रोल पैनल
डिफॉल्ट प्रोग्राम फाइल हिस्ट्री मेल
प्रोग्राम फीचर साउंड ट्रबल शूटिंग वर्क
फोल्डर यूजर अकाउंट्स विंडोज डिफेंडर फायर
वॉल ये टूल सबको सबने देखा
है तो यहां पर आप कॉन्फ़िगरेशन करते हो
यहां पर जो भी आप चेंज करते हो
वह आपके रजिस्ट्री के अंदर चेंज होते हैं।
यह आपको किसने दिया है? Microsoft Windows
ने प्रोवाइड किया
है। पता चल गया कि आप क्या यूज़ कर रहे थे?
उसका इफेक्ट बैकग्राउंड में कहां पर हो
रहा है। अभी पता चल गया कि आप जब यह यूज़
करते हो तो यह किस में मॉडिफिकेशन करता
है? आपकी Windows रजिस्ट्री के अंदर
मॉडिफिकेशन करता
है। किसी को भी नहीं पता था
यह। दैट इज द पावर ऑफ नॉलेज। जो मेरे दबा
दी जाती है। यूज़ सब कोई करता है हर चीज को
बट नोबडी नोज़ कि बैकग्राउंड में बिहाइंड द
सीन क्या कर रहा है यह।
ओके नेक्स्ट Windows रजिस्ट्री इज
क्रिटिकल टू ओवरऑल हेल्थ ऑफ Windows? हाउ
कैन वी प्रोटेक्ट इट? अभी जो Windows
रजिस्ट्री है सबको पता है कि Windows की
हेल्थ के लिए सेहत के लिए काफी क्रिटिकल्स
हैं। तो इसको हम प्रोटेक्ट कैसे कर सकते
हैं? क्या हाउ वी कैन रिकवर फ्रॉम करप्टेड
कीज़ एंड हाइव्स? अगर कोई की या हाई लोकेशन
विंडोज़ रजिस्ट्री की अगर करप्ट कर गई या
क्रैश होगी तो उसको हम उसको रिकवर कैसे
करेंगे? किसी को पता है?
डज एनीवन
नोज़ कि Windows को हम प्रोटेक्ट कैसे करते
हैं रजिस्ट्री की को और खास करके जब आप
करप्टेड कीज़ और हव्स हैं या आपका कोई भी
अगर रजिस्ट्री को छोड़ दो। आपका कोई
प्रोग्राम भी अगर करप्ट कर जाता है तो आप
उसको रिकवर कैसे करते हो? या कई बार आपने
Windows को इंस्टॉल
किया और अपडेट किया और अपडेट करने के
बाद वह अपडेट सही से काम नहीं
किया तो फिर आप उसको रिकवर कैसे करते
हो? आप उसको करते
हो रिस्टोर पॉइंट से। Windows रजिस्ट्री
इज़ क्रिटिकल टू द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
स्टेबिलिटी। इफ इट गोज करप्टेड और
मिसकॉन्फिगर इट कैन कॉज क्रशेस बूट फेलियर
और स्ट्रेंज सिस्टम बिहेवियर टू रिकवर
फ्रॉम करप्टेड कीज़ एंड हाइव्स वी कैन यूज़
रिस्टोर पॉइंट। अब इन कीज़ और हाइव से हम
क्या करने रिकवर करने के लिए क्या यूज़
करेंगे? रिस्टोर पॉइंट्स का। अब ये
रिस्टोर पॉइंट्स होते क्या है? ए रिस्टोर
पॉइंट इज ए स्नैपशॉट ऑफ क्रिटिकल सिस्टम
फाइल्स, रजिस्ट्री सेटिंग्स, ड्राइवर्स
एंड सम एप्लीकेशन कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस एट ए
स्पेसिफिक पॉइंट इन ए टाइम। इट अलाउ यू टू
रिवर्ट योर सिस्टम बैक टू दैट स्टेट
विदाउट अफेक्टिंग योर पर्सनल फाइल्स।
बेसिकली क्या होता है कि रिस्टोर पॉइंट
आपके एक पर्टिकुलर किसी आपके रजिस्ट्री की
सेटिंग्स का आपके ड्राइवर्स कुछ एप्लीकेशन
जोेंट एप्लीकेशनेशंस होती हैं या कुछ
क्रिटिकल जो सिस्टम फाइल्स होती है उनका
एक स्नैपशॉट होता है। अगर किसी भी कारण से
आप उस रजिस्ट्री के अंदर चेंज करने की
कोशिश करते हो, ड्राइवर के अंदर चेंज करने
की कोशिश करते हो या उस पर्टिकुलर फाइल की
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन चेंज करते हो या फाइल को
अपडेट करते हो, तो कई बार वह क्रैश या
करप्ट हो जाती हैं। लेकिन फिर भी आपकी
Windows क्या करती है? बाय डिफॉल्ट उसको
रिकवर करके स्मूथली रन करती है। बिकॉज़ ऑफ
दिस रिस्टोर पॉइंट। यह हमेशा आपके
सिस्टम्स में अवेलेबल रहता है। रिस्टोर
पॉइंट हमेशा आपके सिस्टम में अवेलेबल रहता
है। लेकिन आपके पर्सनल जो फोटो हैं,
डॉक्यूमेंट्स हैं, उसको रिस्टोर पॉइंट के
अंदर नहीं आती। ओनली यही कौन-कौन सी फाइल
रिस्टोर पॉइंट के अंदर आती फिर Windows
रजिस्ट्री सिस्टम फाइल्स जैसे डीएलएसल्स
हैं, ड्राइवर्स हैं जो आपने प्रोग्राम
इंस्टॉल किए वो आपके आते हैं या
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल रिलेटेड टू द सिस्टम
स्टेट वही आपके रिस्टोर पॉइंट के अंदर आते
हैं। इसके अलावा कोई भी आपके फोटो, आपके
पर्सनल डॉक्यूमेंट्स वो आपके रिस्टोर
पॉइंट में नहीं आते। ओके? तो रिस्टोर
पॉइंट ही रिस्पांसिबल होता है आपके सिस्टम
को क्रैश होने से बचाने के लिए। जब भी
आपने कभी देखा होगा Windows को आप अपडेट
करते हो और वो अपडेट अगर सक्सेसफुल नहीं
होता तो आप क्या करते हो फिर से आपके
पुराने अपडेट में जाके जो पहले वाला जो
अपडेट अपडेट था इससे पहले उसी में आपका
अपनी विंडो को क्या कर लेते हो बूट कर
लेते हो या ऑटोमेटिकली Windows क्या करता
है कुछ देर तक तो उसको रिकवर करने की
कोशिश करता है न्यू वाले न्यू जो Windows
अपडेट के हिसाब से काम करने की कोशिश करता
है लेकिन कुछ अटेम्प्ट के बाद अगर वो
सक्सेसफुल नहीं होता तो ऑटोमेटिकली
प्रीवियस में ही क्या करता है वो रन करता
है और आपको दिखाएगा
नॉट अपडेटेड सक्सेसफुली। दैट इज द रीज़ ऑफ
स्टोर पॉइंट। रिस्टोर पॉइंट। यह कारण आपका
रिस्टोर
पॉइंट। उसके बाद हम बात करें व्हेन आर
रिस्टोर पॉइंट। अब यह रिस्टोर पॉइंट कब-कब
क्रिएट होते हैं व्हेन सॉफ्टवेयर इज
इंस्टॉल्ड यूजिंग द Windows इंस्टॉलर। कोई
भी हो सकता है। Windows के द्वारा आपने
इंस्टॉल किया है या कोई भी पैकेज इंस्टॉलर
है या अदर इंस्टॉलर जिसको पता है कि
रिस्टोर पॉइंट कहां पर है। Windows के
अंदर रिस्टोर पॉइंट कहां पर है? जिस भी
इंस्टॉलर को पता है तो वो क्या करते हैं?
जैसे ही सॉफ्टवेयर इंस्टॉल होता है, उसका
एक रिस्टोर पॉइंट के अंदर उसका बैकअप
क्रिएट कर देते हैं। व्हेन Windows अपडेट
इंस्टॉल व्हेन अपडेट इंस्टॉल न्यू अपडेट
टू द सिस्टम। जब भी Window क्या करता है
कि नया अपडेट इंस्टॉल करता है तो Windows
का तो उससे पहले उसका एक रिस्टोर पॉइंट
में बैकअप लिया जाता है। दैट इज व्हाई
आपका नया अपडेट अगर काम भी नहीं किया तो
आप पुराने अपडेट से ही काम चला लेते हो।
व्हेन यूजर इंस्टॉल अ ड्राइवर जब कोई भी
यूजर एक ड्राइवर को इंस्टॉल करता है जो
डिजिटली साइन नहीं है या डिजिटली साइन
होने से पहले जो ड्राइवर था उसका भी एक
बैकअप रिस्टोर पॉइंट के अंदर क्रिएट किया
जाता है व्हेन यूजर मैनुअली क्रिएट ए
रिस्टोर पॉइंट या यूजर मैनुअली भी क्रिएट
कर सकता है आपके रिस्टोर पॉइंट को ओके
यूजर क्या कर सकता है मैनुअली भी रिस्टोर
पॉइंट को क्रिएट कर सकता है दैट इज़ द
टॉपिक ऑफ आवर Windows रजिस्ट्री मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं आपको किस तरीके से देखने को
मिलता है आपका रिस्टोर पॉइंट तो रिस्टोर
पॉइंट के लिए आप क्या कर सकते हो? Window
X आप Window एक कीवर्ड होता जो विंडो वाली
आपने देखी होगी ना आपने देखा होगा विंडो
की एक देखने को मिलती है एक कीबोर्ड।
Window प्लस में एक्स प्रेस करोगे तो आपको
देखने को मिलेगा यहां पर गो टू सिस्टम।
जैसे आप सिस्टम पर क्लिक करोगे तो आप देख
सकते हो यहां पर यह सिस्टम है। यह रहा गो
टू सिस्टम। यहां पर देखिए सिस्टम
प्रोटेक्शन में जाना आपको। गो टू सिस्टम
प्रोटेक्शन। यहां देखिए
यू कैन अनडू सिस्टम चेंजेस बाय रिवर्टिंग
योर कंप्यूटर टू प्रीवियस रिस्टोर पॉइंट।
ओके? आपका सी के अंदर रिस्टोर पॉइंट
कॉन्फ़िगर है। कॉन्फ़िगर रिस्टोर आप यहां से
कॉन्फ़िगर में जाके कॉन्फ़िगर भी कर सकते
हो। देखो टर्न ऑन है। यहां पर करंट यूसेज
16 GB दिया हुआ है लेकिन 2% यूज़ किया अभी
तक। ओके? नाउ। तो, यह आपका रिस्टोर पॉइंट।
आप चाहो तो एक अलग से भी रिस्टोर पॉइंट
क्रिएट कर सकते हो। ओके? दैट इज योर
रिस्टोर पॉइंट। एक और चीज बता देता हूं
रिलेटेड टू योर Windows रजिस्ट्री जो आपको
मैं दिखा देता हूं कि हमेशा आपके
सॉफ्टवेयर यूज़ करते ही रहते हैं Windows
रजिस्ट्री को। गो टू मैं आपने डाउनलोड भी
अंदर था। सिस्टम सिस्ट इंटरनल टूल्स था
सूट है। मैं इसके अंदर एक मेरे पास एक टूल
है प्रोसेस
मॉनिटर हम हम ये प्रोसेस एक्सप्लोरर ये
रहा। नहीं नहीं प्रोसेस मॉनिटर है। ये रहा
डबल क्लिक किया। यस किया ओपन देखिए यहां
पर।
ओके ये रहा। ये देखिए ध्यान से। अभी मैं
एक काम करता हूं। नीचे चलता हूं सबसे पहले
क्योंकि लाइव चल रहा है ये। अपडेट होता
है। लाइव अपडेट होता है ये। यह
देखो
देखो अब यहां पर नीचे देखो यह चल रहा है
इतनी फाइल्स यूजिंग है अभी ये देखिए सारी
की सारी रजिस्ट्री की यहां पर हाईलाइट कर
सकते हो लेकिन मैंने अभी यहां पे शो ओनली
रजिस्ट्री एक्टिविटी देखिए hvc exc
रजिस्ट्री क्यूरी ये देखा यहां पर ये
देखिए देखो देखो देखो देखो देखो मतलब
सिस्टम में कितनी देखो 54% इवेंट इवेंट
देखो इतने इवेंट अभी करेंटली चल रहे यह
देखो आपको दिखाई दे रहा होगा नीचे बॉटम
में तो सारे इवेंट अभी चल रहे हैं। देखिए
तो यह अभी भी लाइव है। लाइव आपके सिस्टम
में देखो हर जगह आपके रजिस्ट्री देखो
रजिस्ट्री की से रीड एंड राइट रीड एंड
राइट रीड एंड राइट रीड एंड राइट देखो
सक्सेस सक्सेस नो मोर एंट्रीज नेम नॉट
फाउंड सक्सेस सक्सेस ये देखिए ये इस तरीके
से देख सकते हो आप देख सकते हो यहां पर तो
ये इस तरीके से आप अपने सिस्टम में चेक कर
सकते हैं कि कौन सी प्रोसेस कौन सी
रजिस्ट्री को यूज कर रही है। तो दैट इज द
टॉपिक ऑफ द डे एंड आई होप सबको मजा आया
होगा। सबने देखा होगा और सबको समझ में भी
आ गया होगा और शायद रजिस्ट्री रिलेटेड
आपको कोई भी डाउट नहीं होगा। तो Windows
फंडामेंटल में पढ़ाने के लिए तो बहुत कुछ
है। पढ़ाने के लिए तो अभी अगले 10 सेशन और
डिलीवर कर दूंगा मैं Windows फंडामेंटल के
अंदर। मेरे को तो इतना पता है।
बट अभी उसको पता पढ़ाने का फायदा नहीं है
क्योंकि मैं आपको पढ़ाऊंगा तो यू गेट ओनली
बोर। आपको लगेगा कि बस वी आर एथिकल हैकर्स
व्हाट वी आर लर्निंग। तो आप खुद से
इंटरेस्ट ले पढ़िए। जो इंपॉर्टेंट
इंपोर्टेंट था मैंने आपको पढ़ा दिया था और
बाकी जोेंट चीजें आगे आएंगी इवन आपके जो
एडवांस कोर्स में होंगी तो ड्यूरिंग कोर्स
आपको पढ़ा दिया जाएगा। चाहे Windows हो
चाहे Linux हो। बट अभी तक के लिए इतना ही
था। और Windows की नेक्स्ट जो क्लास होगी
उसमें आपकी सीएलआई की जो कमांड्स हैं उस
पे हम डिस्कस करेंगे कि Windows की कमांड
जो कमांड प्र्ट के अंदर कौन-कौन सी कमांड
आप रन कर सकते हो क्योंकि इट इज़ वेरी
यूज़फुल ड्यूरिंग योर पेन टेस्टिंग जर्नी।
बिल्कुल Android में प्रोसेस होते हैं।
प्रोसेस हर जगह होते
हैं। मैंने आपको बताया ना रजिस्ट्री की
अप्रोच को ओनली आपके Windows ही यूज़ करती
है। बाकी जितने भी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है वो
कॉन्फ़िगर करते हैं टेक्स्ट फाइल में।
बिल्कुल। आपके जो भी चाहे Linux हो चाहे
कोई भी हो। आपके कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल को डील
करता है टेक्स्ट में। कभी भी देखना। Linux
की भी टेक्स्ट फाइल वो देखना जो भी आप
टेक्स्ट फाइल में कोड लिखते
हो। तो विनोद
भाई लोग आते ही
नहीं। पहली बात तो यह है। दूसरा क्या है
कि अभी यस बिल्कुल बेस्ट आरसी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
फाइल्स ऑफ द लाइक एच के करंट
यूज़र्स। तो लोग आते ही नहीं तो भाई क्या
फायदा है बनाने का?
क्योंकि प्रॉब्लम इज दैट कि पहली बात तो
पेन टेस्टिंग के लिए पूरा Windows पढ़ने
की जरूरत नहीं है और Windows को अगर आप
पूरा पढ़ा भी दोगे तो आप बोर हो जाओगे
क्योंकि Windows एक कितना पढ़ सकते हो आप।
आपके एक लिमिट है। वो लिमिट को क्रॉस
करोगे तो आपको फायदा नहीं है। तो उतना
पढ़ो जितना काम चल रहा हो। बेसिक के लिए
इतना पढ़ो। एडवांस के लिए जैसे-जैसे आगे
बढ़ेंगे। खुद थोड़ा सा बुक से पढ़ो। थोड़ा
सा रिसर्च करो। थोड़े से जो इंस्ट्रक्टर
टॉपिक आएंगे मेरे जैसे जो टीचर्स हैं वह
पढ़ा देंगे बस फिर एनफ है। बाकी तो सारी
चीजें खुद से ही सीखनी है।
यस 50 एक्सपेक्टेड 20 इज़ कमिंग। दैट इज
व्हाई आई एम मैं डिले करूंगा अभी सेशंस
को। अभी मैं Windows में भी कुछ क्लासेस
के बाद आई विल टेक रेस्ट बिकॉज़ मैं क्यों
अपना टाइम वेस्ट करूं? ऑब्वियसली
यार आई विल टेक टाइम। आराम से पढ़ाऊंगा।
बिल्कुल क्या दिक्कत है?
किसी को कोई डाउट है क्या?
बुक्स है Windows के लिए मैं फाइंड आउट
करता हूं। आप पढ़ सकते हो फिर मैं बता दूं
आपको। नहीं लोकल एनुमिनेरेशन वाला जो
टूल्स का मैं डायरेक्टली यूज़ कर सकते हो।
वो तो Python का टूल था ना। तो डायरेक्टली
मैंने यूज़ जैसे आपके सामने स्क्रीन पर यूज़
किया था तो आप ऐसे यूज़ कर सकते हो। एक बार
उस क्लास में जाइए और जैसे मैंने उसको यूज़
किया ऐसे ही आप यूज़ कर सकते हो।
साइबर प्रोटेक्टर तो मैं आपको बता देता
हूं कि अभी आपकी एथिकल हैकिंग की क्लासेस
चल रही हैं जिसमें डे 36 तक हमने टोटल 36
क्लास को डिलीवर कर दिया है। तो हमने
बिल्कुल जीरो शू इंटरमीडिएट का टारगेट रखा
हुआ है। तो स्टार्टिंग में हमने बिल्कुल
बेसिक से स्टार्ट किया था। जो विंड आपकी
पेन टेस्टिंग की जो स्किल्स होती है, पेन
टेस्टिंग की जो मेथोडोलॉजीस हैं, उनके
बारे में डिस्कस किया था। एनुमरेशन करना
सिखाया था। कुछ टूल्स के बारे में डिस्कस
किया था। और कुछ सीटीएफ परफॉर्म किए थे।
Linux के ऊपर हमने पेन टेस्टिंग की है। बट
Wind Linux को हमने बीच में छोड़ दिया।
बिकॉज़ ऑफ़ माय जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम क्रैश हो
गया था। तो Linux को भी कंटिन्यू करना है।
और अभी Windows की भी Windows का
फंडामेंटल हमने डिलीवर किया लास्ट सिक्स्थ
क्लास में। और एक या दो क्लास में और
फंडामेंटल क्लियर हो जाएगा। देन उसके बाद
हम शिफ्ट करेंगे Windows की पेन टेस्टिंग
जर्नी के ऊपर। देन फिर फॉललोड बाय Linux
की पेन टेस्टिंग के साथ इसको कंप्लीट कर
देंगे। देन जो बाकी जो टॉपिक बच जाएंगे
आपके वीओआईपी की ट्रैफिक एनालिसिस है वो
मैं सिखाऊंगा बट यह सारी चीजें टाइम लेंगी
क्योंकि आप लोगों की वजह से तो अभी जो
करंट सिनेरियो चल रहा है आपका Windows का
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम फंडामेंटल्स चल रहा है।
नहीं यह क्लासेस रोड नहीं लगती। यह
क्लासेस अभी हर थर्ड डे पे आती हैं और बट
अभी और डिले होगा क्लासेस में क्योंकि
स्टूडेंट्स नहीं आते
हैं। तो सेशन को एंड करते हैं। अगर किसी
का कोई सवाल नहीं है तो हम सेशन को एंड कर
सकते हैं। और किसी को कोई सवाल पूछना है
तो प्लीज मुझसे पूछ सकता है।
पवन आपको क्या करना है सिंपली मैं आपको
बताता हूं आप कांटेक्ट नंबर की जरूरत नहीं
है डायरेक्टली गो टू माय YouTube चैनल
डेफोन एकडमी और आपको क्या करना है सिंपली
दिस माय लाइव क्लास है और
सेव
से क्लास
सिक्योरिटी
अभी
अभी आया
अभी आया अभी
मैं अभी है
नमाज़ नमाज़
ओके तो सबको
क्लियर तो किसी का कोई सवाल है
प्रभ आवाज आ रही है मैंने बंद तो कर दिया
शायद अब आवाज नहीं आएगा तो एक्चुअल में
डेस्कटॉप ऑडियो ऑन था दैट इज व्हाई
ओके तो सेशन को एंड करते हैं फिर
अगर किसी को कोई डाउट है तो मुझसे पूछ
सकते हैं
ओके तो एक काम करते हैं अभी सेशन को एंड
करते हैं। ओके बाय-ब गुड नाइट टेक केयर
एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन।